bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat à suivre sur notre
antenne les travaux de l'OPEX de
l'Office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
lundi 19 novembre députés et sénateurs
se sont réunis autour d'une table ronde
pour comprendre les leçon a tiré de
l'étude très controversée du professeur
Seralini sur le maïs transgénique NK 603
table ronde que je vous propose donc de
voir tout de suite je vous remercie
toutes et tous d'être venu malgré des
contraintes de calendrier on a dû
décaler décaler la date parce que je
crois que l'Office Parlementaire
organise depuis maintenant plus de 20
ans des débats publics on a été on a été
je crois les premiers au Parlement à
organiser des débat public et
contradictoire comme le faisaient depuis
longtemps les Américains et
que ce débat entre scientifique
parlementaire presse publque c'est je
crois nécessaire pour reprendre le mot
de de notre ministre Stéphane Lefol
c'est nécessaire pour arriver au débat
démocratique il faut encourager les
lieux de débat et finalement dans
beaucoup des dossiers qui ont été
abordés là c'est l'inverse des lieux de
débat qu'on a vu puisque c'est très
souvent des oppositions quand contre
quand sans que on échange des arguments
et qu'on essaye en échangeant des
argument de voir comment on peut arriver
à un débat fondateur sur à la fois les
biotechnologies ce qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui mais comme vient de le dire
le ministre plus largement sur
l'agroécologie et une des questions qui
a été posé c'est est-ce que dans
l'agroécologie il y a une place pour les
biotechnologies et et où est-ce que où
est-ce que les biotechnologies en soi je
parle pas des des OGM qui sont
actuellement utilisés en France on ont
une place dans
l'agroécologie dans le dans le cas
présent ce débat s'incrit de long daque
au Parlement et ceux qui me connaissent
malheureusement on apparaît comme un peu
des anciens combattants depuis longtemps
dans la mesure où en 98 on a abordé pour
la première fois ce débat dans ce lieu
au niveau du Parlement et en 98
conscient déjà des
des ruptures dans l'opinion publique on
avait organisé la première conférence de
citoyens et qui je crois Ava été une
réussite parce qu'on avait demandé sur
un sujet aussi compliqué aussi complexe
que celui des OGM et moi même si le
ministre l'a dit j'emploierai jamais le
le j'emploie pas le terme
d'OGM plutôt je l'emploie je l' déjà dû
l'employer trois fois mais mais je pense
que c'est un terme inapproprié parce que
il doit y avoir autant d'organismes
génétiquement modifiés qu'il y a
d'événements de changement d'un
organisme vivant ou d'un gène et que on
n'est pas dans la même problématique sur
de la transgénèse pour fabriquer un
médicament de de pour insérer un gène
chez une bactérie en milieu clos ou
insérer un gène dans des plantes
génétiquement modifiées c'est pas les
même problématique comme on devrait pas
employer le mot de nanotechnologie et on
le dit de la même manière euh au au au
niveau de l'Office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques j'avais eu ensuite été
dans la Commission des quatre sages euh
avec Didier Sicard Jacques Testard euh
et euh et le le le le directeur à à
l'époque de de la société française de
l'alimentation le Centre national de
l'alimentation le CNA pardon euh et et
on avait donc rendu un rapport j'ai
également une mission d'information en
2005 et j'ai bien sûr participé à la loi
de 2008 puisqueon parle pas de rien au
niveau législatif si l'Office a tenu à
organiser la présente audition
publique c'est parce que Monsieur
Seralini que je remercie d'être là
l'article que vous avez publié dans une
bonne revue a suscité des
controverses et que au sein de la
communauté scientifique que ces
controverses on les a plus vu au niveau
des médias que en en discussion
scientifique d'ailleurs ça a été dans
une récente publication que je viens de
voir qui a été signée il y a eu
plusieurs publications signées par un
grand nombre de scientifique
j'ai j'ai vu une critique qui disait
l'Académie aurait dû donc vous pourrez y
répondre l'Académie aurait dû organiser
ce débat comme il l'avait fait pour le
changement climatique et je pense que
les lieux de débat comme l'Office
Parlementaire c'est quelque chose
d'important et pour le biochimiste de
formation que je suis il s'agit d'un
impératif catégorique
tant les anathèmes qui ont été prononcés
depuis quelques semaines non' pas à mon
avis fabriquer la construction d'un
consensus sur les différents sujets qui
nous préoccupent sur les biotechnologies
en
effet il y aura les questions
d'existe-il une relation entre OGM et
tumeur point qui a été essentiellement
repris par les médiia
et est-ce que donc vous allez pouvoir
répondre à cette question et s'agissant
de l'opportunité d'instituer des études
de toxicité à long terme l'ancèe qui va
s'exprimer à souligner la rareté de
telles études précédent celle du
professeur Seralini d'autres disent
qu'au contraire sur d'autres animaux que
les rats ces études ont déjà existé il y
en a eu beaucoup euh et l'ANS et le HCB
ont approuvé le principe de telles
études il faudra donc essayer de voir si
effectivement les études de toxicité
subchronique c'est-à-dire ce qui est
nécessaire à un moment donné à voir si
un réel danger c'est suffisant ou si sur
des constructions comme les organismes
génétiquement modifiés il faut aller
plus loin j'espère que vous répondrez
également à la question qui était qui
avait été conclue par l'Académie
américaine des sciences en 1987 c'est
vieux qui disait que il y avait aucune
raison de penser et si vous pensez
autrement que entre une construction
faite par l'homme transgénèse sur un
organisme génétiquement modifié et
d'autres méthodes de sélection d'autres
méthodes de modification des plantes il
y avait aucune raison de penser que les
mécanismes changeaient fondamentalement
donc esanogm est une construction très
différente d'un phénomène de
modification de plantes par d'autres
techniques de de sélection végétale
j'espère que vous pourrait également
répondre à cette question qui est qui
est une question importante pour autant
et j'ai vu un certain nombre d'articles
l'instauration éventuelle d'une durée
supérieure à 90 jours prévu par les
lignes directrices sur l'évaluation
sanitaires des OGM risque de poser
certaines questions délicates comment on
va définir la notion de long terme et
vous vous êtes exprimé là-dessus par
rapport à la vie d'un animal faudra-t-il
retenir la seule durée de 2 années et
donc assimiler toute étude à une étude
de cancérogénèse enfin une modification
des lignes directrices en ce sens
sera-t-elle compatible avec la
réglementation communautaire qui impose
de réduire c'est un autre point la
souffrance des animaux et l'angoisse des
animaux de laboratoire et l'office
parlementaire est bien placé pour en
parler puisque le professeur Jean-Louis
tour membre de notre office a rendu une
étude sur cette question le recours à
des méthodes alternatives pourrait
s'avérer nécessaire est-ce qu'il y a des
méthodes alternatives et j'espère que un
certain nombre d'entre vous pourrait
nous éclairer à ce sujet un autre point
de la controverse touche à la puissance
statistique nécessaire pour garantir la
robustesse d'une étude à cet égard lors
de l'audition de l'anè vous monsieur
Seralini vous aviez dit que la puissance
statistique de votre étude était
insuffisante mais Monsieur B mais
Monsieur B a dit vous vous exprimerez
j'ai lu j'ai lu ça dans le rapport de
l'an sur sur une figure mais bien sûr
pas sur ce quoi on porta les
statistiques dans notre étude
c'est-à-dire sur la biochimie mais
Monsieur B j'ai vu un article qui disait
lui donc je je je rééquilibre qui disait
que finalement avec des études de sur un
faible nombre de rat on voyait des
directions et que et que et
que vous exprimerez vous vous exprimerez
vous vous
exprimerez bon je me suis jamais exprimé
sur ce ah c'est c'est Monsieur c'est
c'est vous monsieur à côté de vous
monsieur
V donc je vous laisse vous exprimer
toujours est-il que j'ai lu des choses
qui était contradictoire et enfin ne
conviendrait-il pas d'effectuer des
études non plus seulement sur des rats
mais aussi sur du bétail et sur d'autres
d'autres animaux quoi qu'il en soit il
importe de voir que les études
toxicologiques prendront une importance
croissante en raison du développement
fulgurant des technologies et la
structure de plus en plus complexe de
certains OGM qui pourront contenir
plusieurs gènes interagissant entre eux
à l'évidence une telle évolution
imposera des recherches accrues mais
celles-ci pourront s'effectuer de façon
fructueuse que dans un climat qui serait
un climat plus apaisé c'est là une une
obligation car c'est la place de la
recherche sur les biotechnologies en
France et en Europe qui est qui est qui
est importante on n'a pas utiliser des
OGM dans des constructions de trangèse
pour toutes les formes d'agriculture je
crois que le ministre vient de le dire
mais est-ce que on peut se passer de
recherches sur ces sujets en tout cas la
conférence de citoyens avait là-dessus
demander qu'on puisse poursuivre
l'effort de recherche et disait-il y
compris en plein champ on aura
l'occasion tout à l'heure de
d'auditionner euh des représentants des
directeurs de recherche de l'inrad
Colmar où il y a eu une expérience qui a
été détruite et qui don donneront leur
avis à ce sujet voilà euh cette
introduction euh je m'excuse si je n'ai
pas été précis mais je reviendrai je
crois que c'était votre voisin qui avait
dit ça donc je m'excuse de l'attribution
de cette attribution que je vous ai
faite mais on aura l'occasion je crois
de reparler en détail de ce que chacun a
dit sur ce sujet en tout cas ce qui m'a
paraissait important c'est qu'au
Parlement on puisse avoir ce débat qui
j'en suis certain ou je l'espère sera
cet après-midi apaisé et je donne tout
de suite la parole à Franck Foures qui
est directeur adjoint l'évaluation des
risques en charge de l'alimentation à
l'anèe je demanderai à tous ceux qui
vont s'exprimer de tenir dans le temps
de on est dans les temps mais de 7
minutes 7 minutes impérative parce que
certains m'ont dit c'est pas assez au
Parlement c'est 5 minutes et ensuite
dans les échange d'arguments de 2
minutes parce que autrement il arrive ce
qu'il arrive dans tous les réunion de ce
type c'est-à-dire qu'on arrive à la fin
de la réunion sans que une personne a pu
poser une question et on a eu un peu
comme on l'a vu malheureusement dans la
presse on a vu des échanges d'arguments
sans que il y ait discussion sur ces
arguments donc je compte sur vous vous
aurez l'occasion de reparler vous aurez
l'occasion quand vous direz quelque
chose que vous avez vous avez
l'impression que c'est pas c'est pas
juste vous avez pas dit ça vous leverz
le doigt comme vous avez su le faire et
on aura je l'espère quelque chose de
plus vivant qu'une somme de ologogue sur
ce sujet monsieur Foures 7 minutes vous
avez la parole merci Monsieur le
vice-président messieurs les sénateurs
Messieurs les Députés nous sommes très
heureux de de participer aujourd'hui à
cette réunion au programme que l'on
trouve passionnant euh et de d'avoir
l'occasion de présenter ici le travail
qu'a pu fournir l'INS à la demande du
gouvernement suite à la publication de
de de l'équipe du professeur gileric
Seralini euh donc le gouvernement nous a
posé deux questions la première était de
savoir si cette étude était conclusive
quant au risques sanitaires euh et
remettait en cause les évaluations
précédentes du maïs nk603 ou de
l'herbicide Roundup et puis de
déterminer si cette étude et l'ensemble
des connaissances scientifiques
disponibles euh justifier une remise en
cause ou du moins une évolution des
lignes directrices actuelles de prévu
dans la réglementation
européenne donc pour répondre à ces deux
questions l'Anses a créé un un groupe
d'expertise collective d'urgence he
puisqu'on avait un temps relativement
limité euh en rassemblant des experts
aux compétences variées en puisant dans
les collectifs d'experts qui sont qui
ont été récemment renouvelé au sein de
l'aness donc bien sûr nous avons veillé
à la question et au risque de conflit
d'intérêts et vous trouverez à ce sujet
à la fois la composition du groupe qui a
été constitué pour répondre à cette
saisine en annexe de la vie de l'agence
et puis sur le site de l'anes vous
trouverez aussi les déclarations
publiques d'intérêt de l'anemble emble
des membres qui ont qui ont participé à
ce
travail alors cette étude le monsieur le
vice-président l'a signalé le ministre
aussi a suscité de vives débats dans la
communauté scientifique et l'agence a du
coup souhaité prendre du recul et
travailler dans la sérénité loin des
polémiques en adoptant une attitude qui
soit à la fois enfin qui allie à la fois
une grande rigueur scientifique mais
aussi une attitude de vigilance et
d'écoute vis-à-vis des signaux qui
pouvaient être tirés d'un tel travail
quel que soit ces
faiblesses donc première chose nous
avons souhaité entendre les principaux
protagonistes de de ces débats alors
l'auteur de l'étude bien sûr que je
remercie d'avoir accepté de de de nous
rencontrer donc on a reçu le le 10
octobre dernier qui nous a fourni un
certain nombre d'élément d'information
qui étit manquant mais qui nous a
présenté largement son étude et nous a
donné un certain nombre de données aussi
qui nous ont permis de de de
d'approfondir notre travail et on a
rencontré aussi le président de
l'association Génération futur et puis
nous avons sollicité la firme
Monsanto qui nous a proposé une
contribution écrite donc l'ensemble de
ces pièces he que ça soit les les
auditions de des de de l'association
Génération futur ou la rencontre avec
l'équipe de du professeur Seralini étant
étant intégralement disponible sur le le
site de l'agence ainsi que la
contribution écrite de la société
Monsanto alors également tout en
maintenant et en menant de manière
complètement indépendante notre
expertise nous avons veillé à nous
coordonner avec les autres instances qui
ont travaillé sur cette études hein donc
au niveau communautaire l'EFSA mais
aussi nos nos homologues allemands et
néerlandais et puis bien sûr au niveau
français le le
HCB alors nous nous rejoignons très
largement sur plusieurs points
essentiels de faiblesse de l'étude mais
dans le travail de l'incest nous avons
cherché à aller au-delà d'une simple
analyse critique et euh en faisant le
point sur les autres études disponibles
et en essayant d'analyser les
conclusions qu'on pouvait en
tirer alors sur les alors vous avez ici
un un tableau je le commenterai pas dans
le temps qui m'est imparti mais
globalement sur les 24 études de plus de
90 jours qui sont référencées dans la
littérature et dont on fait auquel on
fait souvent référence monsieur le
vice-président en parlait tout à l'heure
les experts n'ont retenu au final que
deux études jugé comparables entre
guillemets à celle de gileric Seralini
et c'est à ce titre que nous avons tenu
à souligner l'originalité de cette de ce
travail au-delà de ses faiblesses car en
plus ce travail associé une des tests
sur une plante génétiquement modifiée
associé à l'herbicide à laquelle cette
plante est
résistante donc je je ne vais pas
détailler l'ensemble et les résultats de
ces ces trois études elles sont elles
sont toutes les trois assez différentes
hein une étude alors ce qui est
important de savoir c'est que ce sont
trois études qui sont des études qui ne
sont pas des études réglementaires
c'est-à-dire des études commandité par
des industriels pour autoriser un
produit il s'agit bien d'études de
recherche euh à savoir donc des études
menées par des institutions des des
scientifiques qui appartiennent à des
institutions publiques donc l'étude de
Sakamoto est une étude qui est
commanditée par un institut de santé
publique japonais l'étude de Malatesta
est financée par le ministère de la
Santé italien et puis l'étude de gileric
serralini qui nous conduit à être
ensemble aujourd'hui
donc globalement les deux premières
études euh même si elles mettent en
évidence certains effets he notamment
pour l'étude de Manuela Malatesta sur
des sur l'expression des protéines
hépatiques ne mettent pas en
évidence desffits sur les de pathologie
ou de mortalité sur les sur les animaux
alors l'étude de gileric Seralini en
en à
l'inverse les auteurs les auteurs dans
leur résultat avancent un certain nombre
de de points sachant que cette étude
avait avait l'ambition de d'étudier la
toxicité à long terme d'un maïs tolérant
au glyphosate et en parallèle d'un
herbicide le Roundup GT+ via la la voie
alimentaire donc ce ce protocole d'étude
prévoit un nombre important d'animaux il
y a 200 animaux dans cette étude mais
teste aussi un grand nombre de
paramètres hein trois doses d'OGM non
traité trois doses d'OGM traité au
glyphosate et également trois doses de
round up euh donc il s'agit du pardon
trait round traité au round up oui
pardon pardon et trois doses de de round
up dans l'autre boisson euh donc il
s'agit donc d'une étude large qui suit
un grand nombre de paramètres
biochimiques mais qui répartit les
animaux en 20 groupes he de 10 animaux
donc des des des lot de petite taille ce
qui a été beaucoup
commenté alors je vais passer assez
rapidement sur ces sur ces points mais
chacune des trois études he présente un
certain nombre de de de faiblesses hein
je l'ai sur le transparent précédent je
les détaillerai pas mais l'ancess
considère que la faiblesse centrale de
l'étude de de gileric Seralini réside
dans le fait que les conclusions
avancées par les auteurs sont
insuffisamment soutenues par les données
présentées dans la publication et après
analyse statistique des des données de
mortalité et de d'apparition de de
tumeur ou de pathologie aucun écart
statistiquement significatif n'a été mis
en évidence entre les différents groupes
traités et les différents et les groupes
témoins alors le choix de du type de rat
a beaucoup été décrié et il faut savoir
que c'est une lignée de rat qui est
couramment utilisé pour ce type
d'expérience et pour nous ce choix n'est
pas en soi à critiquer et il ne pose pas
spécifiquement de problème pour des
études courte mais cela dit il est
important de savoir et ça a été beaucoup
dit dans la presse que cette souche de
rat à un certain âge développe
spontanément des pathologie notamment
tumorale et de l'ordre de 50 % de
tumeurs spontanées sur cas à l'âge de de
2 ans donc avec Dia par groupe he sur
des études aussi longues on ne peut
déceler que des différences très
importantes entre les groupe et ainsi on
a de fortes chances de ne rien pouvoir
mettre en évidence de significatif et
c'est ce qu'on a observé en analysant
cette
étude aussi l'expertise menée par
l'agence conclut que les résultats de ce
travail de recherche ne permettent pas à
elle seu de remettre en cause les
évaluations réglementaires précédentes
sur le maïs nk600 3 ou le
Roundup mais le deuxième point que nous
avons souhaité mettre en avant c'est
qu'il y a peu d'études sur les effets
potentiels d'une exposition pendant une
durée de vie entière à des OGM associés
aux préparations
phytopharmaceutiques alors cette
préoccupation d'une meilleure prise en
compte des effets à long terme des EGM
ou des effets chroniques rejoint la
position prise par l'agence en 2011 qui
visait à renforcer les conditions de
réalisation de ces études qui sont
requises dans le cadre
réglementaire alors notre proposition
que l'agence a formulé dans un rapport
devrait être prise en compte assez
rapidement au niveau du du cadre
réglementaire européen et nous
souhaitons vivement que ce cadre soit
rapidement
adoptoups
excusez-moi est-ce que j'ai est-ce que
j'ai encore une minute une minute très
bien donc mais audelà deette ité de
renforcer le cadre réglementaire que
l'INS a déjà signalé l'agence aimet
plusieurs recommandations qui nous
semblent particulièrement importantes la
première c'est d'engager de nouvelles
études sur la question des effets à long
terme des OGM associés aux pesticides et
nous considérons que ces études
devraient être menées sur la base de
protocole d'investigation précis et bien
sûr l'UNC est prête en association avec
d'autres partenaires à travailler à
l'établissement des principes généraux
de tel protocole d'étude
la deuxième recommandation c'est de
renforcer les recherches sur les effets
des expositions cumulées ce qu'on
appelle dans notre jargon les effets
cocktails il faut savoir que l'agence
s'est investi sur ce sujet depuis assez
longtemps et a lancé en 2007 un projet
qui est actuellement soutenu par la NR
qui est le projet dit
périclè le projet arrive à son terme
mais on considère aujourd'hui qu'il faut
mobiliser davantage la communauté
scientifique sur ce sujet qui relève
aujourd'hui clairement d'une
problématique de recherche fondament
pour mieux documenter les interactions
potentielles et là notamment entre les
substances actives et les
coformulants enfin notre troisème
recommandation he constitue la la
conséquence logique des deux points
précédents mais elle s'inscrit dans un
contexte qui dépasse largement celui des
des OGM c'est le besoin que l'on a en
tant qu'agence de pouvoir mobiliser des
financements publics nationaux ou
européens qui soit dédié à la
réalisation d'étude d'envergure euh ou
de recherche d'envergure visant à mieux
consolider les connaissances dès lors
qu'on a on est face à un risque
sanitaire qui est insuffisamment
documenté voilà j'espère avoir tenu le
temps imparti merci beaucoup donc
maintenant je donne la parole à Monsieur
Franck
Foures pardon monsieur Jean-Christophe
pagè
excusez-moi qui est président du conseil
scientifique du Haut Conseil des
biotechnologies monsieur Paget je sais
pas où il est je suis là ah il est là il
est là vous êtes là merci merci monsieur
le Premier Vice-Président merci
messieurs mesdames les députés donc je
vais avoir une approche un peu
complémentaire de nos amis de de l'an et
qui sera un peu plus précise peut-être
sur les les données de de l'article qui
nous avait été demandé de de commenter
plus modestement que l'an le le comité
scientifique du du Haut Conseil des
biotechnologies et le comité économique
éthique et sociale à qui nous avions
rendu compte de de nos travaux donc se
sont attachés à visualiser l'étude qui
avait été proposé et puis à en faire une
analyse scientifique avec la rigueur
scientifique qui est celle qui a
toujours prévalu aux analyses en
particulier du du comité scientifique
donc pour se faire je je vais reprendre
le le la structure de la souche de rat
qui avait été utilisé puis faire des des
commentaires assez rapides je pense que
je vais rattraper un petit peu du temps
qui a été utilisé par Lan et je
conclurai je conclurai par non mais je
vais être assez rapide vous allez voir
dans sur certaines diapositives donc et
je je conclurai par le le ce qui va nous
attacher
aujourd'hui qui sont les les
perspectives et ce que l'on peut
éventuellement faire alors le la souche
de R spracdolé est une souche qui est
relativement
ancienne qui est une souche qui est
connue pour faire des tumeurs présenter
des tumeurs de façon spontanée elle
présente également d'autres anomalies
des anomalies hépatiques des anomalies
rénales de façon très très importante et
vous voyez ici sur le schéma qui est
présenté donc une espèce d'historique
alors il n'est pas exhaustif mais il
vous montre les variations donc de
d'apparition de tumeurs je me suis
cantonné au tumeurs Mamère qui sont les
tumeurs qui ont été
présenté comme vous le savez au travers
de de de la publication donc il y a une
oscillation entre 30 et 70 % de de de
tumeurs et ce qui avait été avancé c'est
que ces tumeurs pouvaient résulter de de
l'alimentation en particulier en nk603
et en Roundup et on voit que sur
l'historique en
définitive ça a l'air relativement
indépendant de de d'apparition donc nous
nous sommes attachés à une étude en
particulier qui est ici qui était une
étude euh interne au fournisseur de rat
qui est la société harl et nous avons
repris les fréquences de de ces tumeur
chez chez le rat donc on est dans le la
fourchette et on a vérifié que ces rats
avaient été nourris par une alimentation
qui était exente d'OGM donc ces OGM
n'avaient été traités ni par le le
Roundup ni alors vraisemblablement
peut-être par d'autres herbicides mais
en tout cas pas par le le Roundup et
toutes les autres alimentations euh de
des rats de laboratoire contiennent des
aliments qui sont issus de de de culture
vraisemblablement traité donc premier
constat le les rat font spontanément des
tumeurs et avec des des oscillations
relativement importantes ça nous a
permis euh de au travers du d'une
analyse qui a été produite par notre
statisticien nous avions mandaté deux
statisticien je ne suis pas revenu sur
la structure de de du groupe de travail
qui avait été mis en place hein vous la
trouverez dans notre avis donc ça ça
nous a permis de de voir les différents
groupes euh autant les groupes contrôle
qui sont en bleu que les groupes qui
sont l'objet du du test et de voir qu'il
se distribuaient de façon homogène et
qu'il n'y avait pas de de groupe qui
sortaiit du Lot peut-être le groupe
contrôle femelle qui est un peu
particulier mais globalement l'ensemble
de de de ces groupes étaient dans la
distribution que l'on pouvait attendre
de de cette étude de cette souche pardon
donc on ne peut pas conclure qu'il y ait
une différence euh d'apparition de
tumeur et de relation tumeur survie chez
ces rats ensuite une des revendications
était l'apparition plus fréquente et
plus précoce euh de ces tumeurs là
encore on a fait une bibliographie
relativement exhaustive et c'est un peu
difficile à voir mais ce que l'on
constate c'est que euh aussitôt que 12
semaines des tumeurs apparaissent chez
des animaux qui de laboratoire donc là
encore on ne peut pas dire qu'il y ait
une différence entre la souche
euh spracdolet standard quel qu'elle
soit quel que soit l'origine et ce qui
est observé de dans
l'étude ensuite il y avait une
revendication donc qui était une
revendication de d'anomalies biologiques
alors ces anomalies biologiques elles
ont été validées statistiquement bon
nous avons fait dans notre avis un
commentaire sur cette l'analyse
statistique mais bon admettons qu'elle
soit correcte euh est-ce qu'elle est
indicatrice d'une atteinte
physiopathologique particulière alors on
constate première chose c'est que les
données biologiques sont obtenues à à 15
mois il y a eu des des séries mais
celles qui sont commentées dans
l'article sont celles qui sont obtenues
à 15 mois et que en revanche les données
histologiques sont des des données qui
sont obtenues en fin d'étude on c'est
pas d'ailleurs très précisément et en
tout cas l'autopsie des des animaux donc
là ça ça pose une une question de de
temps entre le l'observation
histologique et le la validité de des
données biologiques de plus sur aucune
des données histologiques il n'est
présenté de fréquence de ces anomalies
on ne sait pas sur un même foi en fait
de de d'animal traité ou non on peut
trouver une zone morphologiquement
normale et une zone anormale on ne sait
pas d'où vient quoi et il n'y a aucune
donnée donc ça ça ne renforce pas ce ce
ces observations en TER de d'anomalie
les atteintes rénales donc la
revendication d'anomalie rénale est
basée essentiellement sur un recueil des
des urines toutes les autres anomalies
qui sont revendiquées en fait sont un
peu discordantes je vais vous le montrer
l'anomalie les anomalies hépathtiques il
en est de même et les désordres
hormonaux qui sont utilisés comme des
variables explicative des des tumeurs
pour nous ne sont pas supportés par les
données alors je je vais passer
rapidement euh sur ces anomalies rénales
voyez ici une des des figures euh on on
il y a plusieurs paramètres qui sont
liés les uns aux autres donc ils sont
pas indépendants donc c'est normal
qu'ils varient de de la même façon mais
ce qui est étonnant c'est que le
paramètre centrale de l'insuffisance
rénale qui est théoriquement
l'augmentation de la créatininémie la
créatinine dans le sang et bien lui se
trouve diminuer de la même façon le
potassium qui est un autre paramètre se
trouve diminuer et enfin un paramètre
qui qui était attendu qui était euh le
le la présence de protéines dans les
urines n'est pas retrouvée non plus donc
les paramètres hépatiques je ne vais pas
m'étendre dessus donc nos nos
conclusions sont relativement simples
sur le plan observationnel he puisque il
y a une première partie qui était
purement observationnelle on ne peut pas
distinguer la souche de race pragdolet
de l'étude de du comportement et quels
que soient les traitements qui lui ont
été donnés des des des de la souche
standard sur le plan biologique donc il
y a des différences statistiques mais
elles ne sont pas corroborées par aucune
des
analyses qui sont présentées il y a pas
de cohérence physiopathologique c'est la
raison pour laquelle le comité
scientifique du ha Conseil des
Biotechnologies avait conclu qu'il n'y
avait pas d'indication de risque
sanitaire à la suite de cette étude
voilà pour la première partie donc
maintenant quelles sont les suites hein
nous sommes dans la la suite de de de
cette étude
donc je crois que ce qui ce qui est
important et ce qui a
été vraiment extrêmement délétaire c'est
la délégitimation de des instances
d'expertise tant sur le plan français
que sur le plan européen et là je dois
dire que il faut que nous retrouvions
une légitimité de ces instances
d'évaluation la diversité des instances
dans les États-membres la diversité la
compétence et la sélection des experts
dans les instances comme le Conseil des
Biotechnologies me semble très très
largement suffisante elle est plurielle
elle est très contradictoire je peux
vous le garantir de par les discussions
que nous avons au moins au comité
scientifique et je crois que c'est
important de de renforcer ces ces ces
questions il faut également que nous
puissions rappeler la portée des études
réglementaires actuel qui sont de de
trois ordres euh et euh c'est bien
confirmé qu'elles sont des indications
et que c'est parce que il n'y a eu rien
de révélé à l'occasion de ces études que
les autorisations ont pu être données
bon maintenant une des questions qui
nous avait été posé au travers de de la
sisine que nous avions reçu
conjointement avec l'aness était de
savoir si l'on devait ou non réviser les
lignes directrice donc c'est un travail
qui est un travail de relativement
longue haleine qui est un travail qui
qui a déjà été entrepris de façon
récurrente par l'AFSA qui a précédé l'an
l'EFSA le remet assez régulièrement sur
le le son agenda et donc c'est une
question que que nous allons aborder
donc je vais pas vous donner la la
méthodologie précise hein je crois que
c'est totalement inutile donc les les
limites des études réglementaires nous
les connaissons le comité scientifique
du HCB les rappelle de façon
relativement régulière hein les
pétitionnaires passent très souvent
d'innocuité alors même que ils n'ont pas
les les la puissance statistique pour
pouvoir revendiquer cette question
néanmoins euh il n'est pas objectivé de
de toxicité ce qui ce qui explique
peut-être les décisions qui sont prises
alors queles sont quelles vont être les
les orientations hein le il y a
plusieurs euh travaux qui sont en cours
euh en particulier sur le le plan des
financements
européens il y a deux
projets qui sont un qui a démarré qui
est le projet grass qui va revoir ces
ces études d'amont avec cette
préoccupation de de de diminuer le
nombre d'animaux qui sont mis en œuvre
dans ces études et puis un projet plus à
plus long terme auquel nous nous croyons
relativement bien qui est cette question
de de la surveillance émiologique et
probablement la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes actuellement provient en
particulier de cette absence de données
de suivi épidémiologique qui aurait pu
constituer une espèce de de garde-fou
sur les éventuels effets de des OGM
voilà je je vais m'arrêter là et je
pense que nous aurons le le temps du
débat j'espère ne pas avoir trop dépassé
s
semblerait merci merci beaucoup et et
donc maintenant on a on a entendu les
les les deux agence qui a été saisie par
le le ministre vous avez entendu les
conclusions monsieur Seralini je vais
commencer par vous et puis après on
alternera avec des gens qui sont d'avis
opposés comme on en a à peu près les le
le le le même nombre on essaiera
d'alterner je vous donne la parole il y
a eu un certain nombre de critiques qui
qui sont faites par l'ANS et par le HCB
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire de
manière globale sur l'étude la manière
dont vous l'avez réalisé la controverse
et puis euh euh défendre les arguments
de la publication scientifique que vous
avez
publié merci Monsieur le vice-président
alors tout d'abord je remarqu je
remarquerai que ce n'est pas tout à fait
égal puisque l'an et le HCB n'ont pas un
avis favorable à l'étude au niveau du du
temps ensuite je voudrais vous remercier
et souligner que ce débat est un débat
national et que pour nous responsable de
l'étude le débat est international
nation et se situe en ce moment à la
revue food and chemical toxicology qui a
comme il se doit selon l'énorme éthique
publier les réponses de nos adversaires
en particulier monsantau et je dis bien
adversaire puisqu'il demande le retrait
de l'étude alors que moi je n'ai rien de
spécifique contre telle ou telle
entreprise et euh des scientifiques qui
sous forme d'aguisée ou non soyons clair
travaillent pour eux et qui qui
s'exprimeront aussi ici dans cette salle
euh donc je je voudrais dire que pour
nous le donc je demanderai à ceux qui
travaillent pour moi s de le dire avant
ou qui travaill dans leur cabinet de
lobby européen voilà euh
ou avec eux
donc ce travail a mis 4 mois à être
expertisé par la revue qui a évidemment
discuté de tous les points que soulève
l'aness et le HCB et je remarquerais
tout d'abord que ces agences ont pour
rôle d'étudier la validité des produits
de de les mettre de donner des avis euh
pour au ministère de l'agriculture en
particulier pour les mettre ou non sur
le marché et que elles analysent bien
vite des articles scientifiques qu'elles
ne sont pas toujours outillés pour pour
évaluer puisqu'il n'y a pas toujours les
meilleurs spécialistes du domaine euh
dans là-dedans comme le ferait une revue
scientifique internationale en
consultant dans le monde entier il y a
très peu de spécialistes ce n'est pas un
discrédit face aux experts mais il y a
très peu de spécialistes dans ces
domaines dans le monde
entier et je feraai remarquer que votre
présentation cet après-midi porte sur le
maïistre angéque NK 603 alors que notre
étude porte également sur le RUP et
qu'on ne peut pas dissocier les deux
puisque ce maïs transgénique a été
modifié pour
absorber sans mourir du runup qui
évidemment rentre dans la plante sinon
euh il ne peut pas agir et il il va être
présent donc avec certains résidus
certains de ces résidus dans la plante
donc je suis extrêmement choqué euh de
pour moi ce qui est une faute
professionnelle qui consiste pour les
agences à ne pas avoir en même temps
évalué les euh études de la société
Montsanto pour mettre ses produit sur le
marché de façon à ce qu'on parle à
puissance statistique égale par exemple
euh et et je constate que si on ne peut
pas dire que les la puissance
statistique de Monsanto comme vient de
l'admettre Monsieur le Représentant du
HCB n'est pas bonne pour les tests qui
ont permis la mise sur le marché de ces
produits je constate en même temps que
on ne peut pas parler de de différence
entre les les témoins et les traités et
que
pourtant c'est ce qui est c'est ce qui
est fait dans la mise sur le marché du
produit c'estàdire qu'on considère qu'il
a une certaine inocé sinon on ne le
mettrait pas sur le produit et on
commanditerait d'autres types de tests
qui portent d'ailleurs sur les mêmes
rats et sur 10 rats puisque malgré les
20 rats de la société Montsanto il y en
a que 10 qui sont mesurés au niveau
biochimique alors il y a un certain
nombre d'incohérence pour nous à ne pas
avoir et à garder confidentiell les
données de la société Monsanto et
puisque il se trouve que les deux
produits appartiennent à la société
Monsanto que nous avons testé le maïs
transgénique avec ousan randup et le
randup lui-même et d'autre
part de de ne pas comparer les
comparables alors de façon à ce que la
communauté scientifique dans son entier
et pas quelques une quarantaine de de
scientifiques qui ont publié dans la
presse sur ce que nous avons fait de
façon à ce que la société scientifique
dans son entier puisse évaluer les
choses nous avons décidé de mettre chez
un huissier l'ensemble des données
brutes qui ont permis la publication de
ce travail et de les rendre publiques le
jour où soit une agence mais j'ai cru
comprendre que même les données du RUP
n'étaient pas en France ou à l'fsa mais
seulement dans le bureau allemand qui a
réalisé très très vite une contreétude
une une contreexertise défavorable sur
notre étude le BFR donc j'espère que le
ministre de l'Agriculture qui doit aller
en Allemagne il nous il viennent nous le
dire pourra demander ces données les
données sur lesquelles il travaill
puisque les agences devraient les avoir
eu quand elles permettent les
autorisations les réévaluations d'un
produit euh donc j'espère que ces
données seront mises également chez un
huissier et qu'on pourra alors comparer
les comparables ensuite il y a un
certain nombre de critiques mais
j'entends laassurdité aussi de euh de de
ces critiques alors il est clair que
nous nous sommes adressés à la société
Arlan avant de commencer l'étude euh ils
ne peuvent pas garantir de nourriture
sans OGM c'est pour ça que nous avons
avons dû refaire nous-mêmees les
croquettes euh et donc nous avons des
croquettes témoins garanties sans OGM et
sans pesticid alors que ce n'est pas le
cas pour l'ensemble des données
historiques donc cette fluctuation elle
est plutôt du au non testage de la
nourriture des animaux de laboratoire
comme c'est le cas pour le bétail
aujourd'hui que la fluctuation entre 30
et 70 % des tumeurs qu' a un résultat
scientifique valable euh nous le pensons
donc nous avons pu comparer à des
contrôles qui ne mangeait pas d'OGM ni
de résidus de pesticides ensuite nous
avons dosé évidemment les pesticides et
les OGM que nous avons euh fait pousser
dans la nourriture des
traités ceci pour parler euh de des
tumeurs spontanées des rats et je crois
qu'il faut comparer à ce que nous avons
obtenu c'estàd quand on contrôle la
nourriture en OGM et en pesticide on a
une tumeurs chez les mâles et chez les
mâles témoins et euh trois 4 sur
l'ensemble de l'étude avec les femelles
traitées et 5 6 à la toute fin les tout
derniers jours de l'expérience sur les
femelles témoins c'est-à-dire queon a
tris à quatre tumeurs chez les témoins
pardon
euh normaux pendant l'ensemble de
l'expérience et 5 6 à la toute toute fin
et donc on peut comparer 14 tumeurs ou
10 tumeurs à cela évidemment nous
n'avons fait aucune statistique et les
statistiques de Monsieur laviel ou du
HCB ont conclu à euh l'absence de
puissance suffisante pour dire que il y
avait un effet lié au traitement et
absence de puissance pour dire qu'il n'y
avait pas d'effet le au traitement donc
voilà ce que révèlent les statistiques
sur les figures 1 et 2 selon le HCB
cependant nous avons fait des
statistiques avec une très bonne
puissance très discriminante sur
l'ensemble des données biochimiques et
là on a en effet des paramètres qui ont
une cohérence biologique avec euh euh
les euh les résultats obtenus puisque
nous avons eu en fait trois groupes de
paramètres et le fait qu'il ne soit pas
lié n'avait pas d'importance dans la
méthode oplsda que nous avons ou qu'il
soit lié n'avait pas d'importance dans
le domaine dans le domaine des des
études variables multiples nous avons
obtenu que les paramètres hépatiques
rénaux certains paramètres hépatiques
rénaux et les paramètres hormonaux qui
conduisent lorsqu'ils sont déréglés
aussi au développement de tumeurs
hormonodépendantes nous avons obtenu le
fait fa que ces paramètres étaient
déréglés et ça c'était fait à l'aveugle
puisque le statisticien ne connaissait
pas les traitements et d'autre part les
anatomopathologistes agré qui ne
connaissaient pas les traitements non
plus et qui ont été payés pour faire
leurs analyses et bien sont des
anatomopathologistes qui nous ont dit
que les pathologies les plus fréquentes
étaient les pathologies hépatiquees
rénales et surtout les tumeurs mamères
et que la le deuxième organe ne plus
touché chez la femelle bien sûr tout
cela par rapport au contrôle était
l'hypophyse et donc nous savions que
nous avions là des pathologies
hormonodépendantes chez la femelle et
des pathologies hépatiques et rénales
chez les mal et ils nous ont même
attesté que les morts étaient dû à ces
pathologies puisque dans certains cas
pour éviter la souffrance nous avons
même dû les euthanasi à cause de ces
pathologies en particulier quelques
jours avant ce qui aurait été leur mort
naturelle alors
euh le le problème maintenant c'est de
dire écoutez circuler il y a rien à voir
et on va continuer à valider ces
produits ou alors il faut faire
davantage d'études nous remarquons et en
ce sens nous soulignons le l'avis
positif de de l'an que seuls deux études
sont comparables parce que les études de
2 ans sur porc ou sur vache n'ont pas ne
sont pas des études vie entières et dans
les études comparables de loin nous
sommes la plus fouillée et la plus
détaillée tant au niveau du Rundup que
du du maïs OGM nk603 ce qui est certain
c'est que aujourd'hui même le RUP ne
semble pas avoir été évalué plus de
quelques semaines je ne parle pas du
glyphosate qui est un de ces composés
biochimiques nous avons montré très
récemment par une nouvelle étude publiée
dans toxicologie que il y avait des
composés encore plus toxiques dans les
produits classés inertes du rondup et
que le mélange était plus toxique que le
glyphosate lui-même donc il est clair
que si mesdames et messieurs vous
acceptez une société dans laquelle la
composition des produits est tenus
secrèt dans laquelle les analyses de
sang qui sont réalisées par les
industrie est validé par les agences
sont tenue secrète et où un maïs
transgénique n'est pas évalué plus de 3
mois sur la santé et où un herbicide
n'est pas eu évalué plus de quelques
semaines sur la santé et bien les BRV
vous moi je ne l'accepte pas en tant que
scientifique parce que je pense que
malgré le fait que finalement le plus
gros défaut qu'on nous trouve c'est que
nous avons dira par groupe si nous
devions supprimer l'ensemble des études
de biologie qui ont dira par groupe ou
moins je crois que c'est 98 % de la
biologie qui tomberait et donc malgré ce
défaut évidemment nous aurions aimé
réunir 6 millions 20 millions d'euros
et faire une étude avec 20 50 sans rat
euh je crois que nous ne pouvons pas
éviter le inviv aujourd'hui en tant que
scientifique puisque de toute façon
c'est la dernière étape avant de même
par éthique animale parce que c'est la
dernière étape avant de donner ses
produits à manger à l'ensemble des
animaux de ferme et de
laboratoire et puis bien sûr par éthique
humaine parce que vous me permettrez de
toujours préférer un enfant à un rat euh
et bien je crois que si on veut être
dans cette société libre à vous mais
aujourd'hui nous nous nous devons
d'aller plus loin et s'il y a le moindre
doute alors refaisons une étude plus
détaillée nous nous le demandons par
d'autres mettons au point un protocole
indépendant acceptons non pas
l'expertise indépendante qui est un
mythe mais l'expertise contradictoire au
point où nous en sommes les États ont
tellement demandé aux grands instituts
de recherche de travailler avec les
industriels que voyez-vous il y a un
réseau et une corporation d'intérêt qui
s'est développé avec le temps et que
nous devons accepter l'expertise
contradictoire et pour aller vers la
transparence et puis je voudrais vous
dire aussi qu'aujourd'hui la revue food
and chemical toxicologie est en train de
publier notre réponse détaillée à
l'ensemble des critiques et que j'ai
reçu plutôt des commentaires des
éditeurs disant que leur processus
d'évaluation avait été excellent bien
sûr il pouvaiit toujours améliorer les
choses mais que ensuite ils étaient
écœurés par les liens qui avaient été
mis à jour par certains journalistes et
en particulier sur le blog de Rue 89
entre les réseaux qui nous ont critiqué
au niveau international et les les liens
avec l'industrie qui avance
déguisé
donc je crois que aujourd'hui chacun
peut se rendre compte de cela en menant
sa propre enquête donc 140 scientifiques
français ont expliquer que ceux qui
avaient parlé au nom de la communauté
scientifique en fait ou au nom des
académies ben il ne l'accepit pas sans
qu'il y ait eu des libération général
sans qu'on ou alors ceux qui parlent au
nom de la communauté scientifiques sont
en général très présomptueux parce que
la communauté scientifique est toujours
partagée sur des points surtout aussi
sensible que celui-ci et qu'enfin il y a
193 soutiens internationaux de
scientifiques aujourd'hui là vous voyez
les les tumeurs mamères et les
hypophyses qui sont déréglé et puis euh
1 130 associations demandent la
transparence sur les données qui ont
servi à évaluer ces EGM et je crois que
ça serait la moindre des choses
aujourd'hui il y aurait encore beaucoup
à dire dans le temps qui m'est imparti
c'est quasiment impossible je voudrais
simplement vous remercier pour votre
attention merci merci beaucoup donc vous
avez on on va essayer de de de de poser
les questions les unes après les autres
sur le débat là vous avez parler des
autorisations qui étaient données au
niveau européen gerérard Pascal a été au
niveau mondial au niveau mondial et
européen en disant qu'il y avait pas
d'études quand on donnait des
autorisations l'ancè pourra répondre HCB
plus tard mais Pascal ét j'ai pas dit
qu'il n'y avait pas d'études monsieur
leedo j'ai dit que les études à long
terme étaient extrêmement courtes et
même les études de 3 mois ne sont pas
obligatoires et sur la partie
extrêmement courte donc sur les 90 jours
on a déjà auditionné un certain nombre
d'entre vous et dans des auditions à
laquelle vous avez
participé qui qui indiquaiit que
finalement la subpronicité on la voyait
déjà en 30 jours et que si c'était
dangereux sans statistique les 30 jours
et
était suffisant pour détecter quelque
chose de très grave et que sur les
études à long terme sur la létalité mais
je vais laisser Gérard Pascal le dire
puisque il a un avis différent il a
signé un papier différent de ce que vous
dont vous rappelez l'existence tout à
l'heure et je lui donne la parole on on
va alterner monsieur on va alterner si
vous le voulez bien
entre des
des vous aurez la parole juste
après pour 7 minutes essay
mais jeensais que monsurait lui laisser
le temp donc il a il a utilisé le temps
qu'il souitait ainsi que les deux Agen
maintenant 7 minutes chacun et autrement
on s'en sortira pas en temps on a une
somme et je souhaiterais qu'il y a un
débat par la suite merci monsieur le
Premier Vice-Président enfin président
de cette séance d'avoir donné la parole
à un autre ancien combattant alors dans
la première partie de de mon
intervention je jouerai à l'ancien
combattant dans la la seconde partie
j'essaierai d'aborder un petit peu
l'avenir devant le le débat médiatique
actuel qui concerne les
OGM je parlerai PGM de plantes
génétiquement modifié traité ou non par
des herbicides et pas du tout de
produits phytosanitaires parce que mes
compétences ne vont pas jusque là donc
devant ce débat nos concitoyens peuvent
avoir l'impression que la méthodologie
mise en œuvre pour évaluer la sécurité
de ces
OGM tombe du ciel que c'est du grand
n'importe
quoi il n'en est rien cette méthodologie
résulte de développement qui sont
intervenus depuis plus de 25 ans le
travail a commencé en 1983 à l'OCDE par
la mise en place d'un groupe de travail
chargé d'imaginer une méthodologie
nouvelle pour évaluer les risques des
produits issus des
biotechnologies pourquoi une telle
demande qui peut vous surprendre mais
c'est tout simplement parce qu'on ne
savait pas Eton sait pas très bien
encore aujourd'hui évaluer les risques
de d'un aliment à la différence de ceux
d'une molécule chimiquement définie
comme un médicament comme un produit
phytosanitaire comme un additif
alimentaire ou comme un
contaminant avec ces composés on peut
forcer la dose avec un aliment on ne
peut pas forcer la dose et on ne dispose
donc plus d'une marge de sécurité pour
passer de l'extrapolation pour passer de
l'animal de l'expérimentation animale à
la situation réelle sur le terrain du
consommateur exposé à à des
molécules un simple exemple le maïs bien
on utilise des régimes alimentaires avec
33 % maximum de maïs la la teneur
maximum que peut supporter le rat et
bien certaines populations mexicaines
par exemple ont dans leur alimentation
les mêmes quantités de maïs et donc on n
plus de marge de sécurité il fallait
donc inventer une nouvelle méthodologie
au risque de vous surprendre aucun des
aliments que nous consommons tous tous
les jours n'a jamais été évalué en terme
de sécurité
sanitaire sauf quelques exceptions les
aliments irradiés quelques aliments
cuits et réchauffés au
micro-ondes pour le reste l'évaluation
de de ces aliments résulte au cours des
siècles d'une expérimentation en vraie
grandeur un peu brutale l'exclusion des
aliments toxiques par suite d'accidents
mortels je
continue en 1986 il faut quand même
souligner que la France a été le premier
pays à se doter d'une commission
spécialisée la Commission du génie
biomoléculaire au CDE OMS on continu
travaillé ont publié des rapports où ils
ont fait des propositions au début des
années 90 la machine était lancée
l'Union
européenne est rentré dans la partie à
l'occasion d'une question qui était
posée par nos collègues britanniques
quant à l'évaluation du risque posé par
la présence de gènes de résistance aux
antibiotiques dans un maïs pauvre maïs
c'était encore et donc c'était le la
première discussion au niveau de l'Union
européenne en 1980 17 l'OCDE a organisé
en France une
réunion à ossois dans les Alpes et nous
sommes enfermés pendant 3 jours en
retraite pour discuter donc des de
l'évaluation de la sécurité sanitaire
des nouveaux aliments en général mais
évidemment les PGM était au centre du
débat et à cette époque en 97 nous avons
discuté entre autres de
l'opportunité de réaliser des
expériences toxicologiques à 28 jours
alors c'est justement à cette époque que
personnellement j'ai pu
identifier à partir d'une
expérimentation à 28 jours une toxicité
manifeste dans un colza génétiquement
modifié le
GT73 et c'était dû à une teneur en
toxique naturellement présent dans le
cols des glucosinolates qui était
supérieur dans le le lot génétiquement
modifié par rapport au témoins parce que
le témoin avait été mal choisi mais si
vous avez des questions sur ce plan je
suis prêt à y répondre depuis bien
d'autres réunions internationales ont eu
lieu et je voudrais insister sur
l'irruption à partir des années 2000 de
projets de recherche européen donc des
réunion internationale et puis des
projets de recherche qui se développent
en particulier j'ai évoqué donc ici sur
cette diapo le projet en
transfood c'était C c'était un cluster
de cinq projets de recherche dont les
résultats ont été publié dans food and
chemical toxicology je crois que c'est
une revue que vous connaissez bien
maintenant un autre gros projet était le
projet safe foods publié dans food
control dans le même temps l'AFSA créé
en 2003 l'EFSA pardon créé en 2003 a
publié en 2008 un gros rapport sur les
lignes direct
et en particulier sur l'expérimentation
animale ce gros rapport a été publié
dans food and chemical
toxicology quelle est aujourd'hui
l'approche qui est
retenue non
pardon quelle est l'approche qui est
retenue pour évaluer la sécurité
sanitaire aussi bien en France qu'en
Europe sur les recommandations de l'OCDE
et de l'OMS et bien c'est une approche
basée sur le fait que nous ne savons pas
bien évaluer un aliment et que donc ce
qui a été proposé c'est sont des études
comparatives entre une plante
génétiquement modifiée d'une part et
puis un comparateur c'est-à-dire une
plante considérée comme témoin aussi
proche que possible de la plante
génétiquement modifiée et éventuellement
des variétés du commerce et donc on va
comparer à différents niveaux un tas de
choses euh au niveau moléculaire donc la
la composition du génome de ces deux
plantes on va comparer l'aspect de ces
plantes cultivé en ser puis cultivé au
champ comparer les performances
agronomiques les résistances à
différents agresseurs donc des
micro-organismes des virus des insectes
la résistance aux facteurs
climatiques les rendements agronomiques
et puis au moment après la récolte des
comparaisons de composition avec de très
nombreux paramètres les protéines et les
acides aminés les acides les lipides et
les acides gras les vitamines les
oligoéléments les toxiques naturellement
présents les composés
antinutritionnels puis on va comparer in
silico c'est-à-dire à l'ordinateur la
séquence des protéines nouvellement
produites dans les PGM à des séquences
qui figurent dans des banques de données
de protéines reconnues comme toxique ou
de protéines reconnu comme allergène
on va faire des tests invitro euh de
digestibilité des protéines qui sont des
indices de risque de risque allergène
des tests invivaux de toxicité aigu sur
ces mêmes protéines nouvellement
produites et puis des tests
subchroniques à 90 jours alors là il y a
une petite discordance entre euh l'Union
européenne qui n'exige pas
réglementairement ce type
d'expérimentation à 90 jours et puis la
France qui depuis plusieurs années a
souhaité disposer de ces études à 90
jours la méthodologie donc a évolué en
permanence alors aujourd'hui que
faire et
bien il faut encore améliorer cette
méthodologie
mais ma position personnelle consiste à
dire que ce que nous recherchons et est
loin de moi l'idée de dire il n'y a pas
il n'y a aucun risque avec ces plans
génétiquement modifié mais euh s'il y a
un risque tout ce qui est fait
auparavant permet de soulever un certain
nombre d'allumer un certain nombre de de
signaux permettant d'aller plus loin à
chaque fois que quelque chose de
significatif a été observé on ne répond
pas à toutes les questions et donc s'il
y a quelque chose c'est sans doute
quelque chose de un effet discret qui
peut certes manifester des effets
délétaires sur la santé publique à long
terme mais ce n'est pas avec des
méthodes relativement peu sensibles que
nous allons réussir à mettre en évidence
ses effets et
donc dans les dernières années de de
travail à linra j'ai orienté un certain
nombre d'équipes sur de nouvelles voies
et voici ici un un travail qui a qui a
payé quel beaucoup d'années après
puisque j'ai quitté l'INRA début 2004 ce
travail a été publié en 2011 donc il a
fallu 7 ans pour arriver à déboucher sur
des résultat mais en particulier vous
voyez qu'ici le la métabolomique donc
une nouvelle technique une nouvelle voie
d'approche a permis
de publier des résultats intéressants
avec un autre un autre maïs
génétiquement modifié le MON 810 et puis
mais ça a déjà été évoqué donc je vais
passer très très vite sur ces aspects
deux projets deux recherche sont en
celui-ci a démarré et et l'autre va
démarré au début de l'année 2013 13 euh
vont voir des équipes françaises
participer à ces projets et en
particulier donc des des équipes que
j'avait
euh aidé à se mettre sur un certain
nombre de voies
nouvelles voilà le projet Marlon qui a
qui a déjà été évoqué et qui est une
étude épidémiologique sur les
animaux et puis en matière de de
pratique beaucoup de projets de progrès
ont été réalisés les déclarations
d'intérêt sont toujours auourd'hui
public donc chacun peut les consulter
avec des modalités un peu différentes
selon l'aness selon l'fsa selon l'OMS
mais toutes ces déclarations d'intérêt
sont
publiques la transparence et bien c'est
vrai qu'il y a eu un manque de
transparence nous en avons discuté avec
gilléc Seralini
longuement c'était peut-être une
mauvaise habitude de de nos
administrations parce que c'était plutôt
au niveau national qu'on pouvait
l'observer des luttes pour
l'amélioration sont intervenus et petit
à petit cette transparence s'est
beaucoup améliorée aujourd'hui j'ai bien
dit que je ne parlais que des PGM et des
PGM traités la transparence est quasi
totale aujourd'hui chacun d'entre vous
peut téléphoner à l'EFSA pour demander
communication de façon électronique de
l'ensemble des dossiers avec l'ensemble
des précisions
inéress BR avec les données brutes
absolument donc c'est à la disposition
de tout le monde l'fsa refuse l'EFSA
refuse de le mettre sur le site mais
chacun d'entre vous peut téléphoner à
l'EFSA et recevra le dossier des données
brutes de chaque dossier
vousz non monsieur le Deo il est clair
que c'est donn son sous copyright si
chacun dans son coin fait l'étude sans
pouvoir parler des données brutes il y a
un grave problème je ne vous ai pas
interrompu pant V présentation donc s'il
vous plaî laiss c'est moi c'est moi qui
lu c'est moi qui lui permet parce que je
l'ai interpellé et c'est normal que
c'est le débat il ne s'agit pas de
donner des données sous copyright que
chacun dans son coin puisse les
photocopier ou les avoir à un moment il
s'agit de donner les données qui
puissent être exploitables
électroniquement pour faire des
statistique à la fois de l'ogmnk 603 et
du Roundup et Monsieur non Monsieur
Pascal bien dit qu'il ne parlait pas des
pesticides et donc il est clair que
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas le cas ceci ne
doit pas être couvert par le secret
industriel les agences l'ont permis en
statuant sur des produits qui nét qui
étaient couverts par le secret
industriel ça n'est pas la fabrication
du produit qui est en cause c'est les
analyses de sang qui ont permis
l'évaluation de ces produits pour qu'ils
soient mis sur le marché à la fois pour
le RUP et pour tous les pesticides et en
même temps pour les OGM et on est loin
d'être à ce point aujourd'hui euh euh
pour que ce soit sur un site public et
non sous copyright que un chercheur
puisse le faire mais qu'il ait à rendre
des comptes et que s'il les mett
publiquement dans un une liste de
statisticiens par exemple une liste de
discussion de statisticiens ça soit
possible donc je demande à tous les
statisticiens qui ont travaillé sur mon
travail puisquil y en a plusieurs de se
fournir les données et de les mettre sur
leur liste de l'ogmnk603 et du Rundup et
après on pourra parler donc j'ai parlé
du NK 603 traité ou non he moi je ne
parle que de choses pour les quel j'ai
une petite compétence donc ces données
sont disponibles elles sont sous forme
informatique donc chaque statisticien
peut utiliser les données brutes les
seules informations les seules
informations qui ne figurent pas sur ces
dossiers c'est le nom des auteurs des
études des études toxicologiques hein
aussi bien des gens qui ont réalisé les
observations anatomoppathologiques que
des gens qui ont réalisé
l'expérimentation animale c'est c'est le
seul secret entre guillemets donc moi je
vais je vais con
j'tais j'ai j'ai j'ai été long donc
personnellement moi je je je suis très
heureux d'avoir eu l'occasion de
participer à l'amélioration de toute
cette approche méthodologique et je ne
prétends pas que tout est parfait et que
au contraire il faut encore progresser
et je suis aussi très heureux d'avoir
participé à titre personnel bon à à à à
ma à mon échelle à la constitution de
l'Agence Française donc de l'fsa d'abord
et de l'ANS aujourd'hui et puis à celle
de l'Autorité Européenne l'fsa je vous
remercie monsieur mtureux pour 30 second
vous aurez là juste tout à l'heure
parler voilà faç c'est la réponse à ça
oui oui non non juste spécifiquement sur
l'accès aux données parce
qu'effectivement d'ailleurs c'est c'est
une discussion qu'on a vu avec le
professeur giléric serralini et de façon
plus globale que les plan génétiquement
modifié pour les pesticides également
aujourd'hui il y a des textes
réglementaires au niveau européen hein
qui précise ce qui est confidentiel et
ce qui doit être mis à disposition il y
a un premier débat he qui est mis à
disposition ça veut dire quoi est-ce que
ça veut dire effectivement mis sur un
site public ou est-ce que c'est transmis
à la demande donc ça c'est un premier
débat et aujourd'hui clairement les
analyses juridiques qui ont été faites
et de ce côté-là il y a des des
plusieurs textes européen réglementaires
qui paraissent un peu contradictoire
dans la façon de les dire donc c'est
plutôt aujourd'hui on met à disposition
à la demande mais pas directement sur un
site rendu public et la deuxième chose
hein qu'il y a c'est que bien souvent
les données qui nous sont fournies sont
fournies sous forme de fichier PDF hein
et ça c'est un autre aspect et en toute
transparence nous on a demandé
d'ailleurs là récemment dans certain
nombre de cas d'obtenir les données sous
une forme effectivement de fichiers
électronique qui permettent sans avoir à
faire un énorme travail de ressaisie
hein de pouvoir travailler directement
sur les données donc voilà je voulais
juste éclairer ces éléments là sachant
qu'en tant qu'agence nous on est tout à
fait évidemment ouvert à la plus grande
transparence dans la limite évidemment
de l'application des textes législatifs
et réglementaires en tant qu'agence
publique on doit effectivement respecter
la
loi Paul de vels vous
avez vous avez fait plusieurs articles
sur les méthodes statistiques vous êtes
membres de l'Académie des Sciences et
vous avez soutenu l'analyse la manière
statistique de gér seraligné est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire pourquoi très bien
je vais commencer par présenter
rapidement je ne représente pas une
agence un laboratoire une structure je
ne représente que
moi-même j'ai travaillé en statistique
depuis plus de 40 ans et en particulier
pour la société Sanofi où j'ai été
expert auprès de la direction générale
pendant 30 ans et je peux vous dire que
j'ai vu beaucoup beaucoup d'études de
toxicologie en particulier dans le cadre
de la mise au point des médicaments
alors libios statisticiens de
l'industrie pharmaceutique ont chacun eu
l'expérience de nombreux candidats
médicaments dont le développement a été
interrompu à cause d'une suspicion de
nocivité qu'elle soit hépatique rénale
de cancérogénèse de thératogénèse et
cetera pour l'homme sur la base de c'est
c'est C suspicion de nocivité pour
l'homme sur la base d'études de
toxicologie animal sans que la
statistique démontre pour autant cette
nocivité par une étude statistiquement
assez puiss
ce qui prime dans ce problème c'est bien
une suspicion de toxicité telle
qu'évalué par le toxicologue
l'entreprise pharmaceutique qui est
généralement en effet très peu disposée
à investir dans la poursuite du
développement au risque les autorités de
santé n'accepte pas de mettre sur le
marché un produit qui a révélé de telle
suspicion pourquoi cette démarche
devrait être différente pour les
médicaments et pour les aliments il est
clair que la statistique est utilisée
dans les études de toxicité d'un
médicament sous l'animal sous forme de
test systématique de pour détecter des
possibles anomalies et c'est fait
davantage en terme de toxicologie
individuelle qu'en terme de
démonstration
desffets je dirais que personne ne sait
vraiment comment décider d'un effet
lorsqu'on a utilisé des techniques
variées intégrant la multiplicité de
tests statistiques appliquer à un très
grand nombre de marqueurs en dernière
analyse c'est souvent le toxicologue qui
analyse résultats qui prononce la
décision et le résultat des tests
statistiques n'étant que l'une des
informations disponibles doit-il en
aller différemment avec un médicament et
un aliment alors j'ai donné un texte où
je développe un certain nombre
d'arguments mais je voudrais surtout
dire deux choses l'étude du professeur
Seralini compose deux parties d'abord ce
qu'il voit dans son étude et ensuite ce
qu'il teste statistiquement et j'ai
plusieurs fois insisté sur le fait que
l'on ne pouvait réellement juger de la
qualité des détections statistiques
c'est-à-dire sur ce qui est
statistiquement significatif au sens
qu'un test statistique le
déclare significatif selon les règles de
l'art et bien c'est il y a deux parties
là-dedans et cette partie on ne peut
juger du paramètrre statistiquement
significatif qu'à partir du moment où on
a les données brutes or il se trouve que
j'ai eu récemment un certain nombre de
données qui m'ont été fournies sous la
forme d'un fichier Excel et ces données
sont simples ce sont les nombres
d'animaux qui sont qui attrapent des
tumeurs au cours du temps euh vous avez
toutes les les toutes les corps de rat
ceux qui les les di rat témoins les dir
rat qui reçoivent une certaine dose
d'OGM et ainsi de suite et j'ai observé
en analysant de façon très précise ses
Cortes et c'estes la survenance des
tumeurs que c'était un superbe processus
de Poisson dans les deux cas et d'autre
part ce processus de Poisson donne une
indication extrêmement précise des taux
d'occurrence de tumeur quotidien pour
les animaux durant la durée de l'étude
et ces tau de tumeurs sont les suivants
pour les animaux témoins c'est-à-dire
ceux qui sont ne sont pas alimenté d'une
façon particulière et bien on trouve de
l'ordre de 3 pour 1000 par jour la
probabilité d'obtenir une tumeur et ceux
qu'ils sont traités par les différents
OGM et bien on trouve par exemple pour
la dose moyenne qui est de 22 vous avez
une dose 11 22 33 je prendrai la dose 22
et pour les animaux qui sont de les
femelles en fait et bien on trouve
une un taux d'occurrence qui est le
triple c'est-à-dire de l'ordre de 1 % ce
qui est énorme mais si on nous dit que
les animaux qui sont utilisés
c'est-à-dire la souche de sprac daé et
pronotumeur c'est clair on voit
l'apparition des tumeurs mais lorsque
ces animaux sont alimentés avec des OGM
ou avec du Roundup et bien c'est au
moins trois fois plus alors vous allez
me dire est-ce que c'est statistiquement
significatif et bien je demande à
n'importe quel statisticien de prendre
une distribution de poisson dont
l'espérance est tr et de calculer sa
répartition c'est très facile à voir il
suffit d'obtenir on a une courbe et euh
vous constaterez que la probabilité
d'observer euh lorsqu'on a une moyenne
de TR et bien une occurrence de 10
tumeurs et quelque chose comme quasiment
voisin de zéro de l'ordre de peut-être
inférieur à 2 ou 3 %. de la même façon
si un animal a un taux de une loi de
Poisson à un taux moyen de 9 ou de 10 la
probabilité d'observer 3 est aussi
extrêmement faible et c'est
effectivement ce que l'on observe
c'est-à-dire que il y a une séparation
extrêmement nette entre les tumeur
observé chez les animaux soit dans le
lot témoin soit dans le Lot traité qui
montre qu' qu'il y a quelque chose qui
est statistiquement significatif alors
je dis statistiquement significatif
est-ce que c'est à 5 % à 2 % à 10 % ça
varie suivant les cas et d'autre part il
y a une certaine incertitude sur
l'estimation mais je prétends que rien
qu'à voir cette cohorte et rien qu'à
voir effectivement les taux d'apparition
des tumeurs on voit quelque chose alors
le professeur Seralini a également
insisté sur le fait que lorsqu'on
observait 50 paramètres simultanément
sur chaque mesure de rat c'était quelque
chose d'extrêmement difficile d'arriver
à les analyser un à un et effectivement
il a utilisé des méthodes statistique de
pls pour arriver à projeter ces
observations multivariées sur des
espaces de dimension inférieur c'est une
méthode moderne c'est ce que tout le
monde fait et en pratique là-dessus on
observe des différences significatives
alors je ne comprends pas que l'anin ou
le HCB se base sur des études de survie
alors les études de survie c'est très
simple on va prendre la durée de vie des
animaux et on va naturellement essayer
de voir s'il y a une différence de durée
de vie significative entre les animaux
du l'eau non traité et les animaux du
l'eau traité chacun sait que dans ce
genre d'étude et bien il faut les
concevoir d'une façon différente pour
pouvoir réellement analyser des courbes
de survie et l'étude du professeur
Seralini il me semble n'était pas une
étude conçue dans ce sens donc je pense
que personnellement je ne suis pas du
tout c du fait que l'étude faite par le
professeur Seralini ne donne pas des
différences significatives alors que
j'ai entendu plusieurs aussi bien le HCB
que l'EN cesse dire le contraire je
pense que ce problème ne pourra être
véritablement réglé qu'une fois qu'on
aura eu les données complètes et même en
même certaines en partie parce que je
dois dire que celles que j'ai eu qui se
présente sous la forme d'un tableau
Excel alors je ne sais pas si je suis
autorisé ou non à le fournir mais mont
convaincu qu'il y avait des différences
significatives très nettes alors est-ce
que ceci suffit à déclarer que le NK 603
ou le Roundup est toxique je n'en suis
pas convaincu non plus pour moi une
étude de ce type n'est qu'une étape et
j'ai tenu dans le document écrit que
j'ai donné à l'annexe en annexe de mon
intervention à préciser que lorsqu'on
fait l'analyse d'un produit
pharmaceutique et bien on passe à
travers tout un ensemble de phases la
phase zé la phase 1 et ainsi de suite et
ces phases sont des phases de
certification ultérieure pour moi
l'étude du professeur Seralini est une
étude fondatrice et il convient de
s'appuyer sur cette étude pour faire des
vérifications ultérieures tout autre
attitude ser ne serait pas scientifique
et je pense en tout cas que on a tort de
vouloir enterrer cette étude directement
en dirant qu'elle ne prouve rien qu'il
n'y a pas de différence significative
personnellement sur le peu de de données
que j'ai vu effectivement j'ai constaté
exactement le contraire et d'autre part
toute mon expérience de statisticien au
service de la communauté scientifique et
en particulier de la communauté
pharmacologique m'a montré qu'il y avait
des quantités d'études où on avait
arrêté la commercialisation ou
simplement les perspectives de
commercialisation d'un médicament sur
des bases beaucoup plus tenues que Cell
donné par le professeur Seralini pour
moi il convient de se poser la question
suivante un médicament et donné à la
consommation de quelques dizaines
quelques centaines de milliers de
patients qui vont le prendre pour
soigner une pathologie un aliment est
donné à des millions et des millions de
personnes qui vont en prendre tous les
jours en permanence donc je pense que
l'étude d'un aliment devrait être faite
de façon beaucoup plus sérieuse que
l'étude d'un d'un médicament alors ceci
étant on objectera que ça coûte de
l'argent que c'est difficile c'est
compliqué mais je ne vois pas pourquoi
on accepterait une fois pour toutes
qu'un produit soit euh ne soit pas
toxique il faut il y a naturellement
toutes les les la pharmacovigilance qui
est utilisé pour vérifier s'il n'y a pas
des effets toxiques que l'on n'avait pas
décelé au départ et ceci permet en
particulier il y a des exemples je ne
vais pas les citer par leur nom mais
vous avez par exemple un débat
aujourd'hui sur la détérioration des
valvules cardiaques par un certain
médicament qui est sur le marché vous
voyez de quoi je parle je ne le sais ai
pas par son nom parce que je crains que
l'on puisse me faire des reproches à ce
sujet et bien je dirais que c'est un
débat scientifique et on a découvert ces
effets à postériori on pourrait citer le
cas de la miante je pense à des
collègues des confrères de l'Académie
qui sont des gloires de la science dans
leur domaine mais qui ont affirmé dans
leur temps que la miante n'était pas
quelque chose de véritablement toxique
et ensuite on approuver le contraire je
pense aussi que les scientifiques
peuvent se tromper mais il ne faut pas à
mon avis lorsqu'on a une étude qui
soupçonne un produit de pouvoir être
toxique on ne peut pas l'enterrer sous
le prétexte que une certaine forme
d'analyse statistique démontre que l'on
ne voit rien et je dirais même plus
ayant je conclus et pratiquant la
statistique depuis des années par
exemple ne serait-ce que pour comparer
deux moyennes on dispose de plusieurs
centaines de tests différents et on
pourrait très bien les appliquer un tour
de rôle pour ensuite dire tiens l'un
d'entre eux décè des différences alors
que les autres ne voient rien ça serait
une façon de tricher avec la statistique
on peut tricher avec la statistique mais
on ne peut pas tricher avec les soupçons
je pense que l'étude du professeur
Seralini nourrit des soupçons et on
devrait la compléter par des études plus
développées afin d'être se savoir si ces
soupçons sont fondés ou
non merci merci
beaucoup ben alors AINS avec la la
permission de madame ricoche vous prenez
votre tour de parole puisque madame je
veux juste répondre sur un point je
juste répond prenez votre tour de parole
parce que les temps sont dépassé bon
alors
vas-y les temps sont dépassés non mais
vous pouvez parler maintenant madame
comme ça vous répondez ce serait
mieux madame parent Massin qui est
président de la Société française de
toxicologie et et et vous essayez tous
maintenant de faire 7 minutes parce
qu'autrement on nous avait annoncé 10
minutes he monsieur le déo on nous avait
je vais juste répondre sur un point
minutes
il faut pas confondre un médicament une
molécule introduite intentionnellement
dans l'aliment une toxine présente dans
l'aliment grâce à Dame Nature et un
aliment il faut savoir Monsieur je crois
que vous connaissez pas très bien la
toxicologie alimentaire un une molécule
introduite dans l'aliment a beaucoup
plus d'études toxicologiques requises
dans un dossier qu'un médicament parce
qu'il n'y a pas de phase
d'expérimentation humaine donc c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça je veux
bien
alors je fais démarrer où c'est le cas
du Round Up dans le maïs NK 603
oui merci merci
Monsieur on est on est à gauche non on
est à
droite on est à
droite vous madame merci Monsieur Merci
monsieur le vice-président mesdames et
messieurs les députés mesdam et
Messieurs les les sénateurs je tiens à
préciser que j'ai été invité ici en tant
que présidente de la Société française
de toxicologie que je suis également
professeur de toxiccologie alimentaire à
l'université de Brest mais je tiens
également à préciser je souhaite que ça
soit noté dans les minutes je suis
expert à l'fsa et en aucun cas je me
m'exprime en tant qu'expert à l'EFSA
dans cette assemblée hein et tout ce que
tout ce don tout ce que je diraai sur
l'fsa est disponible sur le site Web et
c'est là que je l'ai trouvé je m'exprime
pas au nom de l'fsa
alors qu'est-ce que c'est que la société
française de toxicologie c'est 485
membres c'est des industriels et des
académiques aussi les centres français
de toxicologie expérimentale et nous en
avons plusieurs de qualités en France
qui réunit la toxicologie du cosmétique
du médicament alimentaire et chimique et
nous gérons également le registre
européen des
toxicologues européen pour la France
alors je ne vais pas revenir sur la
qualité de l'étude moi ça ne m'intéresse
pas tous ces débat ils ont je pense que
maintenant il faut tourner la page les
avis sont unanimes de toutes les agences
de sécurité alimentaire qui ont évalué
cette étude et moi je crois beaucoup à
l'expertise collective et contradictoire
des agences parce que j'en fais depuis
20 ans dans un autre domaine mais je
sais à quel point leurs avis sont
pertinents et de qualité donc le bilan
est unanime protocole d'étude
inapproprié étude non conclusive bien à
partir de là et bien qu'est pardon à
partir de là et bien quelles en sont les
raisons nous nous sommes posés la
question à la Société française de
toxicologie pourquoi cette étude était
de mauvaise qualité bien nous pensons
que l'association qui a diligenté cette
étude a été très mal conseillée en
toxicologie le centre où a été réalisé
cette étude don je ne sais pas où il a
été réalisé mais manifestement n'avait
pas l'expérience de ce type d'étude vous
me où a été expérimenté
parce que tous les journaux l'ont dit
mais est-ce que c'est bien
Saintour
le l'endroit où a été élevé les rat est
tenu confidentielle puisque ces
structures agréé que le ministère de
l'Agriculture possède travaille
essentiellement avec les industriels et
donc ne souhait pas révéler le nom de
leurs clients
alors alors ce que je peux vous dire ce
que je peux vous dire c'est qu'il y a en
France plusieurs grands centres de
toxicologie labor il y a en France
plusieurs grand centes de toxicologie
expérimentale qui ont l'expérience de ce
type d'étude qui sont adhérents de la
société française de toxicologie et qui
m'ont affirmé que ce n'est pas chez eux
que ce type d'étude avait été mené c'est
bien dommage parce que ils on ont fait
plusieurs dizaines voire pour un centre
une centaine d'études de cancérogénèse
et long terme et eux ils ont des moins
historique alors les conséquences et
bien je pense mesdames et messieurs
qu'il faut que vous preniez peut-être
conscience de conséquences auxquelles
vous n'avez pas pensé et bien l'image de
la toxicologie française dans le monde
est très mauvaise moi je me suis
beaucoup déplacée ces derniers temps à
l'étranger et j'avoue que j'étais pas
très fier d'entendre ce que j'entendais
l'image de la toxicologie au sein du
grand public est aujourd'hui déplorable
et l'image de la recherche universitaire
française car il y a des universitaires
impliqués dans cette publication est
très dégradé à l'étranger en tant
qu'universitaire ça ne me fait
absolument pas
plaisir alors je continue je continue je
continue je je peux continuer monsieur
monsieur monsieur monsieur je vous ai
laissé parler rest je vais vous demander
de rester
calme chacun pourra échanger des
arguments et on pas arriver au
dégradation des images merci monsieur le
président alors toujours dans les
conséquences des centaines d'animaux ont
souffert pour rien un budget important a
été dépensé plus rien pour rien 3
millions de d'Uros m'aon dit et cela m'a
été confirmé la semaine dernière par
Monsieur José bovvet les consommateurs
ont peur à partir d'une étude non
conclusive et je crois que le grand
public a perdu confiance dans la science
et ça c'est très grave dans notre
société alors les actions et bien moi je
vous propose trois types d'actions
quatre types d'actions des excuses
l'association a été mal conseillée donc
elle ne pouvait pas savoir que son étude
était mal conçue et non conclusive et
moi il me semble que des des excuses
s'imposent auprès du grand public des
toxicologues français de la presse et
des politiques je pense aussi que les
médias et on verra ça plus tard euh ne
pouvait pas savoir que l'étude qu'on
leur présentait était mal conçu et non
conclusive parce que je me suis laissé
dire qu'il y avait un embargo et cetera
j'ai rien compris mais ça m'a bizarre et
là aussi je pense que des excuses ça
c'est'est déjà vu des excuses de la
presse dans certaines situations et ça a
toujours était particulièrement élégant
pourra être fait au consommateur au
toxycologue français moi j'ai vu un blog
où il était écrit peut-on faire
confiance au toxycologu ben je peux vous
dire que la société française de
toxycologie ça lui fait très plaisir ce
genre de chos et puis à certains experts
qui ont eu le courage de s'exprimer
avant les avis des agences puisque les
agences ont besoin de temps pour
travailler et que ces experts ont été
quand même extrêmement attaqués alors
qu'ils ont ils avaient exprimé des avis
qui ont été confirmé par les agences
après la deuxième question refaire
l'étude faut-il refaire cette étude nous
sommes dans le poste nous sommes dans
quelle leçon à tié sur quelle hypothèse
moi j'avoue que avant de faire une étude
on pose une hypothèse quelle hypothèse a
été posé sur quelle hypothèse nous
allons travailler que cherche-t-on un
nouveau métabolite toxique
pourquoi pas c'est possible mais sur
quelle
base pourquoi y a-t-il un doute dans les
données qui sont dans ce dossier moi je
connais pas j'ai pas vu le dossier je ne
sais pas je n'ai pas d'avis est-ce qu'il
y a des données de métabonomique qui
permettent de d'alimenter ce doute je ne
sais pas est-ce que l'étude 90 jours a
présenté des signes d'alerte nécessitant
une étude longue j'ai cru comprendre que
non d'après ce que disait
Jean-Christophe p mais une étude 90
jours n'est pas prédictif d'un effet
cancérigène donc est-ce que ça suffit
moi un de mes adhérents qui est un grand
toxycologue mondialement Canu a suggéré
étude 6 mois pourquoi
pas refaire l'étude où et bien compte
tenu de la dégradation de l'image de la
toxicologie française nous avons de
grands centres de toxicologie française
comm une réputation internationale en
France et bien dans ce type de centre et
puis j'ai fait faire deux de vie par
deux centres de mes adhérents un devis
de 1 million d'euros pour 65 50 à 65
animaux par l'eau 1 million d'euros 50 à
65 animaux par l'eau je peux vous le
montrer j'ai suis mon ordinateur et un
autre devis d'une société qui est connue
comme étant un peu plus cher qui est
entre 1 et 3 millions d'euros suivant
les options testées c'est inférieur aux
3 millions d' d'études de de que l'étude
a semble-t-il coûter
quel financement alors là j'ai entendu
partout c'est l'État qui doit financer
alors là je me mets très en colère on ne
peut pas faire financer des études 28
jours des études 90 jours des études de
reproduction sur des toxines naturelles
parce qu'il faut savoir Mesdames et
Messieurs que Dame Nature vient mettre
sur nos aliments des toxines naturelles
qui sont excessivement dangereuses j'en
cite deux ici c'est impossible de les
faire financer et on mettrait 1 million
d'euros pour cette étude moi je moi je
serais très choqué très très choqué
alors après j'ai essayé d'imaginer des
choses avec mes avec mon bureau pourquoi
pas l'association et ses associés qui a
alerté l'industrie et pourquoi pas un
consortium type parabens dans le
problème du paraben et bien il y a eu un
consortium ou les industriels les
associations lafsaps car elle s'appelait
lafsaps à l'époque le LEM ont toutes
participer à une nouvelle étude sous
contrôle je pense dans ce cas-là d'une
structure à définir un financement avec
une structure à définir qui va contrôler
ça une agence quelque chose comme ça on
verra revoir les lignes directrices et
le mode d'évaluation j'ai entendu ça
partout alors je voudrais faire un tout
petit peu d'histoire je vais revenir sur
ce qu'a dit Gérard mais un peu
différemment les M sont arrivés en
France oui oui non non je vais vite les
OGM sont arrivés en France dans les
années 90 il y avait rien dans les
dossiers toxicologiques moi j'en ai
évalué quatre il y a eu un moratoire de
90 à 2004 puis en 2002 création de
l'EFSA 2004 les premières lignes
directrices de l'EFSA sont
publiées depuis l'EFSA a publié 12
lignes directrices en disant ça veut
dire que c'est un travail permanent de
révision des lignes directrices deux
publications complémentaires que je vous
ai mis ici don une dans food chemical
and toxicology on va finir par boycotter
d'ailleurs et puis alors les risques et
conséquences moi je voudrais attirer
votre attention mesdames et messieurs ie
les études toxicologiques que nous avons
l'habitude de faire sont sur des
substances des molécules on a que l'on
mélange à l'alimentation faire des
études
toxicologiques avec une plante entière
c'est quelque chose de très difficile
alors avec le maïs ça va à peu près mais
essayez de tester une tomate en 90 jours
le rat ne mangera jamais de tomate donc
il faut qu'on réfléchisse peut-être à
pas faire des 2 ans pas faire des 90
jours mais être en comme a pu le montrer
Gérard Pascal et puis moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est de voir apparaître des
études entre guillemets similaires pour
solliciter la des financements pour
avoir de nouvelles études et moi ça
vraiment ça ne me plairait pas pour
forcer la main de l'État et puis je
voudrais quand même vous dire que en
France la toxicologie alimentaire est un
parent pauvre elle va très mal et que
nous n serions pas là si la recherche
universitaire et dans les instituts de
recherche était mais était pas était
meilleur était beaucoup plus riche et
donc c'est un appel à mesdames mesdames
et messieurs les députés les sénateurs
prenez conscience que si on ne n'aide
pas la toxicologie alimentaire en France
comme elle est aidée en Hollande par
exemple il y aura plus d'exprès en
toxyologie alimentaire dans 20 ans je
vous remercie merci madame je donne
maintenant la la parole à Monsieur
Robert
B professeur à Pierre et Marie cur et
qui est un spécialiste
plus n ail
des des des phytosanitaires plutôt que
des OGM vous aviez tenu à le dire mais
je vous donne la parole en tout cas pas
des mathématiques ça c'est pas des
statistiques ben je vous remercie
beaucoup et c'est la première fois que
j'ai l'occasion de m'exprimer devant des
responsable de ces agences et voilà je
suis professeur à l'Université Pierre et
Marie Curri je suis en poste à roscov en
Bretagne je suis Classe
E ça comme ça je suis toujours en
fonction et sur la centaine de
publications dans les journaux qu'on
appelle journaux de rang A j'en ai 5 6
peut-être 6 qui concerne directement le
randup et puis deux ou trois annexes qui
vont dans le dans la même idée sur le
modèle expérimental que j'ai pu utiliser
alors vraiment je suis très très content
de prendre la parole et je vais même
faire plaisir à Monsieur le Ministre qui
est pas parti depuis 3 ans je m'oriente
vers une approche qui est une approche
de biologie systémique c'est-à-dire de
consider les choses dans un ensemble et
d'essayer d'étudier avec des
mathématiciens mais cette fois ce sont
des collègues des collègues Renis Nant
niissoir pour prendre les problèmes de
leur ensemble et non pas par petit bout
alors je suis biologiste cellulaire je
ne suis pas toxicologue jeis totalement
incompétent dans le domaine en tout cas
très incompétent dans le domaine de la
toxicologie
réglementaire je ne suis pas médecin je
ne suis pas cancérologue bien que je
travaille avec des cancérologues sur les
mécanques
qui contrôle et qui régule la division
des cellules parce qu'il y a des
problèmes liés au
cancer et je ne suis pas écologiste je
précise aussi que je ne suis ni membre
d'une association militante quelconque
ni membre d'une société ou financé par
une société industrielle quelconque bien
que mon expérience avec le randup soit
totalement fortuite et c'est
à lorsque le journal local a dit que
dans un programme régional nous avions
eu l'intention de faire des tests avec
le Roundup j'ai eu la visite donc des
gens de Monsanto et j'ai pu rencontrer
pour la première fois ces gens qui sont
très agréables par ailleurs aucune
expérience n'avait encore été faite et
le Roundup était pris comme témoin
négatif vous savez que quand on fait des
expériences on prend des témoins
positifs des témoins négatifs alors je
m'adresse beaucoup aux gens de la salle
et aux gens qui sont pas forcément
biologistes les biologistes que je
reconnais certains d'entre vous vous
m'en excuserez mais c'est pour expliquer
un petit peu quand même les résultats
alors il était aujourd'hui question du
de l'OGM et du Roundup alors comme j'ai
pas vu Roundup dans le titre j'ai
demandé au président de séance avant de
venir si en serait question parce que
sinon il était pas la peine que je
vienne sur les OGM je n'ai pas d'avis
spécialement tranché je suis très
favorable par exemple aux OGM qui
permettent de faire de l'insuline pour
traiter les gens malades
je ne suis pas écologiste je ne connais
pas les problèmes des des OGM en plein
champ j'en sais rien alors mon
expérience je vais vous la dire il y a
deux problèmes donc aujourd'hui l'OGM et
le RUP je ne vais parler que du problème
du RUP et il me semble que les gens qui
décident donc il y en a sûrement ici
décident en fonction du rapport bénéfice
risque le problème du bénéfice du RUP et
des OGM je ne vais pas parler il y a des
spécialistes de ça en revanche je
voudrais dire deux choses sur les
problèmes du risque les deux choses sont
la première que le risque est
extrêmement mal évalué et je dirais même
très sous-évalué et la deuxième c'est
quelle est la nature de ce risque alors
je vais essayer d'en convaincre certains
d'entre vous je sais que c'est assez
difficile parce que il faut être au
courant des grandes évolution de la
biologie cellulaire et des connaissances
qu'on a dans cette biologie nous avons
tous un certain nombre de C dans notre
corps à peu près 10000 milliards et
environ 1 milliard de division par jour
et le problème c'est que pendant ces
divisions ont lieu un certain nombre de
d'erreurs alors le contexte dans lequel
nos résultats sont faits c'est sur un
mot alors je vais obliger d'utiliser un
terme anglais ce qu'on appelle le
checkpo checkp de la division des
cellules alors qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette chose alors c'est quelque chose de
découverte relativement récente qui est
passé inaperçu et vous allez tout de
suite comprendre pourquoi lors de la
division de nos cellules pour les
renouveler entre autres ou lorsque nous
partons d'une première cellule initiale
pour arriver à nos 10000 milliards de
cellules nous avons des divisions
cellulaires et nous avons un système de
protection
extraordinaire de la qualité de l'ADN
alors l'ADN qu'est-ce que c'est dans nos
cellules on a deux choses importantes on
a les gène c'est la mémoire et on a les
protéines c'est la vie alors un peu jeis
des jeunes là comme un CD musical c'est
un CD c'est un codage de 0 et de 1 et
puis la musique c'est ce que vous écoutz
avec le CD là c'est un peu le même
principe à chaque division on doit
multiplier les gênnes par
de puis on doit les répartir entre deux
cellules
filles c'est là que se passe un certain
nombre de problèmes et que le checkpoint
est là pour veiller sur nous pourquoi
son rôle est de détecter s'il y a une
erreur si c si une erreur est détectée
au moment de la division trois choses se
mettent en place un arrêt de la division
deuxièmement un mécanisme pour réparer
les erreurs et troisièmement si ça n'est
pas fait un mécanisme qui pousse les
cellules au suicide et qu'on appelle le
mécanisme de
l'apoptose donc normalement des erreurs
dans la division conduisent à aucun
problème et c'est pour ça que ça
beaucoup échappé à la vigilance des
biologistes parce qu'on le voit pas si
on fait pas très attention les premières
expériences que nous avvez fait que nous
avons faites avec le randop nous avons
constaté un problème qui nous paraissait
un problème de Checkpoint nous avons un
certain nombre d'expériences que je vais
pas détaillé ici je crois que c'est pas
le lieu et qui clarifie le ce problème
de Checkpoint c'est-à-dire je précise le
Roundup active le checkpoint de la
division des cellules le modèle utilisé
c'est le modèle embryonnaire de cellules
d'oursin al il y a pas de problème
d'avoir 10 cellules là c'est des
millions de cellules et qui sont toutes
exactement au même stade de la division
il y a pas besoin de mettre de drogue
alors ça gêne certains qui connaissent
pas bien la biologie mais vous le savez
vous les biologiste en tout cas vous le
savez toutes nos cellules ont viennent
d'une cellule unique l'œuf elle-même de
nos parents de nos grands-parents et
cetera il y a un continuum et donc dans
le mécan
des divisions des cellules nous sommes
tous originaires des mêmes cellules et
c'est le mécanisme le plus conservé en
biologie alors qu'on l'étudie chez un
homme chez une femme chez un rat ou le
modèle expérimental nous avons pris un
modèle marin ça revient strictement au
même c'est le même mécanisme sauf qu'on
a beaucoup de cellules et qu'on a une
réponse très vite nous avons démontrer
que des doses appliquées pendant en gros
60 minutes activent le checkpoint de la
division des cellules nous avons fait
des expériences complémentaires pour
montrer que c'est bien parce que ça
touchait l'ADN donc il y a un mécanisme
induit par le roundop qui touche la
division le checkpoint de la division
des cellules nous avons de plus montré
que dans le Roundup il y avait plusieurs
produits enfin ça on le savait non
pardon on l'a pas démontré mais que le
glyphosate qui est considéré comme le
produit actif du randop joue un rôle
dans ce
mécanisme il ne peut le jouer qu'à une
seule condition c'est sil rentre dans
les cellules or le glyphosate tout seul
ne rentre pas dans les cellules et nous
l'avons très clairement montré donc je
reviendrai sur ce point tout à l'heure
parce que c'est un point
déterminant quand on dit produit actif
faut savoir de quoi on parle et je pose
même la question comme je vois qu'il y a
des gens de chez mon santau ici le
glyphosate pur est-il seulement un
herbicide est-il seulement un produit
actif je n'en sais rien et je pense que
c'est plutôt non bon alors j'en reviens
maintenant donc nos résultats nous avons
démontré que il y avait quelque chose
qui activait le checkpoint qu'est-ce qui
peut activer le checkpoint soit direct
ou indirect ça ne peut être qu'un agent
génotoxique qui agit au niveau de l'ADN
et qui activé le checkpoint
or
euh nous avions tous les critères pour
ça alors c'est un espèce de paradoxe en
je vous ai dit en moins de 60 minutes il
a été activé et là je regrette que les
agences d'évaluation nai considéré que
des expériences à temps long or c'est
pas ça le problème le problème c'est les
effets à temps long et les expériences
si on peut avoir la réponse en en 30 ou
60 minutes tant mieux le temps long il
est derrière alors maintenant je vais
vous expliquer alors en 2002 on était
les seuls à avoir trouvé ça bon on a été
très prudent dans nos
publications il faut que je fasse plus
court donc je
vais simplement dire maintenant la
relation avec le cancer alors si vous
permettez donc nous avons ce verrou ce
verrou qui est le checkpoint et il faut
voir un petit peu ça comme une voiture
dans une grande pente avec un frein à
main bien serré elle bouge pas mais vous
desserrez le frein à main la voiture
s'en va le cancer c'est ça maintenant
qu'on a compris qui est très nouveau
mais qu'on a compris c'est-à-dire que
toutes nos cellules nos cellules souches
en tout cas peuvent devenir
potentiellement cancérigènes il suffit
de les induire et elles vont le devenir
en tout cas par un mécanisme bon pas
aussi simple que je le raconte he il y a
des plusieurs étapes il y a des choses
des sélections clonal qui doivent avoir
lieu bon je saute puisqu'on a pas le
temps mais en tout cas il y a une chose
qui est sûre il y a pas besoin
d'attendre 20 ou 40 ans qui est le temps
normal entre l'induction d'un cancer et
les signes cliniques du cancer on peut
le savoir en moins de 2 heur et à coup
beaucoup plus réduit que ce qu'É voquait
madame
paremmassin ça coûte moins cher que des
rats on a beaucoup de cellules il y a
moins de problème de
statistique ça peut
marcher question il faut que le randop
atteigne les cellules humaine pour
déclencher un cancer alors je vois deux
manières de les atteindre soit par
inhalation au moment de son usage vous
me direz c'est que les professionnels
non pour quelqu'un qui a vu des
professionnels utilisés du randup c'est
des nuages quand il est pulvérisé par
avion par hélicoptère en Amérique du Sud
c'est des nuages vous en respirez pas
mal la dernière publication sur la
génotoxicité c'est sur les cellules
bucales humaine et c'est le même
mécanisme génotoxique qui a été démontré
il y a 1500 publications sur le dans les
bases de données 404 sont sur la
toxicité du glyphosate roundamop je
groupe les deux pour simplifier parmi
celles-ci certaines trouvent aucun effet
c'est un juste un problème de dose et
celle qui trouent aucun effet c'est
celle qui teste en général le glyphosate
pur et 80 % à peu près j'ai pas le
chiffre très très précis démontre un
effet toxique du random qui va bien dans
le sens de ce qu'on a trouvé voilà ce
que je voulais dire dans les doses si
j'ai 30 secondes il faut considérer tr
type de dose la dose très aigu Rob pur
vous en buvez en gros il y a des gens
qui sont suicidés comme ça on en meurt
deuxième type de dose c'est la dose
d'usage c'est-à-dire la dose à laquelle
il est pulvérisé
ou dans les OGM la dose à laquelle on le
retrouve dans l'OGM et ça je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas combien on en trouve dans
un OGM puisque 80 % des OGM sont faits
pour être tolérant r up donc on les
asperge de RUP donc ça c'est des
questions
à
débattre
voilà ce que je note sur le deuxème
point c'est que les tests réglementaires
j'ai constaté j'ai vu dans la réponse de
Monsanto à l'ANC que ce qui est mesurer
testé c'est le glyphosate et glyphosate
pur et donc les tests et les doses
réglementaires de 01 microgr par litre
par exemple dans l'eau dans l'eau que
l'on boit là il y en a ça l'air de rien
mais en gros je vous donne l'ordre de
grand pour ceux qui s'intéresse là dans
ce verre il y a 2 millions de milliards
de molécules de
glyphosate ça surprend c'est des
concentrations très basses mais tou
chimist sec faut multiplier par le
nombre d'Avogadro pour avoir le nombre
de molécules réelles une seule cellule
suffit pour conduire un cancer je vous
laisse imaginer bon bien que ce soit
très très peu probable je je suis
d'accord voilà j'ai terminé je vous
remercie mais pour insister sur les deux
points un il peut provoquer le cancer
donc j'ai dit potentiellement
cancérigène et deuxièmement les tests
les doses réglementaires fournies sont
fausses parce qu'elles sont
considérablement sous-estimé je vous
remercie beaucoup monsieur le Président
même si j'ai débordé de quelques minutes
je suis vraiment très content d'avoir pu
dire ce que j'ai dit merci mais comme le
but c'est quand même que vous puissiez
échanger entre vouséond toutes les
questions oui oui mais et que on a on a
dépassé déjà d'une demi-heure donc je
vais demander à Madame ricroche qui va
terminer qui a été l'auteur d'une
d'une méta d'une métaanalyse avec
plusieurs auteurs la co-auteur d'une
métaanalyse sur le même sujet et qui a
qui s'est opposé à l'étude de gilerc
Seralini donc je vous donne la parole et
puis ensuite on aura 20 minutes pour je
crois débattre entre nous et pour poser
un certain nombre de
questions merci monsieur le Président
euh je vais vous présenter ma merci la
diapositive euh à votre vre avis il y a
combien de publications sur les OGM dans
le
monde il y en a 30000 et on les a
rassembléin dans une base de données à
l'initiative de notre collègue feu
jeanberger de de linra elle est
actualisé en permanence grâce
actuellement à un soutien de de linra et
ça permet donc de rassembler toutes les
connaissances scientifiques qui sont
dispersé dans différents journaux
rapports ainsi que des des résumés de de
congrès internationaux alors les enjeux
évidemment pour nous de faire une telle
base de données d'exploiter c'est de
faire un état des lieux uniques de ces
connaissances mondiales mais aussi
transversales à travers des données
venant des sciences vétérinaire
agronomique de l'écologie ou bien de la
biologie moléculaire donc ça permet
évidemment d'éviter de faire d'autres
expérimentations pour les scientifiques
et évidemment c'est un intérêt
social pour les scientifiques les
experts et vous les décideurs politiques
alors il y a deux impacts évaluer sur
les plantes génétiquement modifiées nous
nous avons évalué l'impact sur
l'environnement mais si je parlerais de
l'impact sur la santé donc la première
question qu'on s'est posée euh c'est de
de comparer une une plante transgénique
et la plante la plus proche d'elle
c'est-à-dire une plante sans sans le
transgène donc la question qu'on s'est
posée est-ce que les deux variétés sont
équivalentes en terme de de gènees
d'expression de ces gènes de protéines
et de petits composés chimiques donc
entre euh 2004 et 2010 nous avons euh
trouvé
44 études qui avaient été conduites par
différents pays dont dont l'INRA à
Bordeaux en France tous les laboratoires
étaient euh étaient des laboratoires
publics avec des fonds donc publics dont
une publication en collaboration avec
une entreprise privée donc ça a porté
sur un grand nombre de de plantes comme
vous pouvez le voir et on a publié donc
en avril 2011 avec
jeanberger et Marcel kons alors les
conclusions donc de cette étude c'est
important d'en parler c'est que en fait
il y a plus de différences entre deux
deux variétés qu'entre une variété et sa
variété avec un trangène autrement dit
il y a plus de différence entre deux
variétés de de maïs contentre une
variété de maïs et la variété de maïs
avec un un trangène la deuxème
conclusion des des auteurs de ces 44
études c'est qu'il a un fort impact de
de l'environnement donc d'un champ à
l'autre ça ça
effectivement impacte le profil des
protéines des gènes et des petites
molécules alors la la deuxième question
pardon qu'on pourrait se poser c'est
quand on a établi l'équivalence de l'OGM
et donc de sa référence la la la plus
proche de de lui est-ce qu'il y a un
impact sur la santé hein de la
consommation de l'OGM par les les
animaux donc je vais pas reparler des
études à 90 jours parce que mes voisins
et de de droite et et de gauche m'ont en
ont parlé la question qu'on s'est
vraiment posée était la suivante
qu'est-ce qui se passe sur le long terme
après 90 jours puisque c'est ça qui nous
qui nous rassemble aujourd'hui donc
entre 2002 et 2010 puis qu'on a publié
le le papier qui était en accès sur
internet en décembre 2011 et en en
papier dans le journal en mars 2012 dans
food and chemical
toxicology on a donc trouvé 24 études
donc qui portait à la fois sur le long
terme c'estàd pour nous au-delà de 90
jours et aussi sur plusieurs générations
donc là il y a plusieurs pays qui ont
qui ont participé à à ces à ces 24 étude
euh toutes euh ont été produites par des
laboratoires académiques hein avec donc
des fonds publics alors je vais je vous
ai fait euh pour vous euh Mesdames et
Messieurs les partartementaires et puis
le public hein des des schémas mais tout
d'abord il faut rappeler que il y a un
grand nombre d'organes qui sont qui sont
examinés un grand nombre de paramètres
toxicologiques hein il y a beaucoup
d'observations sur sur le sang euh des
examens biochimique macroscopique
d'organes histologique
microscopique et puis des examens
hisstochimique histopathologique bon
dans dans la la la revue systématique
bibliographique que nous avons faite
vous avez tous ces détails de ces 24
étude alors voilà la la présentation que
je que je fais de de de de notre étude
bibliographique euh les durées vous les
avez en bas vous avez des durées de
nourrissage des animaux qui peuvent être
de 26 semaines donc ça c'est chez les
rat ou les les macaques hein des des des
singes par par une équipe japonaise
notamment sur le saumon pendant 28
semaines 30 semaines par une équipe
italienne sur les souris 52 semaines sur
le rat vous avez des études aussi qui
portent à 65 semaines et puis là on va
vers des des des durées assez longues
notamment pour le rat jusqu'à 104
semaines c'est dire là ils sont ils sont
des vieillards hein aussi des souris
mais à 100 semaines il y a des des
études sur sur les vaches alors je vous
ai donné le le nombre d'animaux qui ont
été nourris aux EGM avec une petite
photo qui représente le le soja le le
riz
et donc c'est ce nombre là hein c'est le
nombre d'animaux qui sont nuris aux OGM
je vous ai pas mis ceux euh donc des des
animaux qui sont nourris par
l'équivalent et souvent à plusieurs do
donc nous avons un total de 340 animaux
qui ont été nourris aux OGM et 436
animaux témoins donc là il y a
776 animaux qui ont été donc sacrifiés
pour être
examinés alors la suite de de l'étude
que nous avons bien sûr divisé en deux
parties c'est les études là qui portent
sur plusieurs générations donc ce sont
des animaux qui sont qui sont nourris
avec un un OGM donc vous voyez encore la
petite icône mais reconnait aussi la
pomme de terre ici et le le tritical le
reste étant le soja et le et le
maïs ce sont donc des des animaux qui
ont été nourris euh avec l'OGM en
comparaison avec des animaux qui ont été
nourris avec la plante la plus proche
sans sans le transanggè et parfois avec
plusieurs doses donc ces animaux ils ont
été observés euh on les a accouplés et
ils ont donné des descendants et ces
descendants là ils ont été eux aussi
Nour selon une certaine durée et ça peut
aller jusqu'à comme ça 20 générations
alors je vous ai mis pour vous des
détails qui concerne donc la durée de
nourrissage de ces animaux à chaque
génération donc pour pour
leurat nous avons une étude qui porte
sur 30 semaines et pour certains animaux
toute la vie là il y en a 10 il y a des
cheèfs qui ont été nourris pendant 9
semaines comme ça pendant deux
générations on passe à trois générations
donc on a des moutons pendant 180 8
semaines qui ont été euh nourris avec
des OGM pour les quatre générations on a
à la fois des souris des rats et des
poules hein vous voyez une diversité
d'animaux testés et ça peut aller
jusqu'à 31 semaines de nourrissage de de
ces poules pour les cinq générations
nous avons des souris des rats bon là
j'ai fait des petites précisions pour
vous montrer que on a fait des
accouplements avec des des nombres de
mâles et de femelles euh donc il vont
jusqu'à euh 7 semaines pour la souris
jusqu'à 153 et enfin chez les cailles
vous avez des une dizaine de de
génération les cailles étant nourris
pendant 32 semaines donc si on fait le
le total il y a 1259 animaux qui ont été
nourris aux OGM donc vous voyez les
icônes sur ce schéma et 1156 animaux
témoins donc ça fait un total de
2415 animaux qui ont été sacrifiés et
examinés alors en conclusion de de de
ces études tout d'abord il
faut signaler la qualité de de certaines
études certaines étant quand même réputé
médiocre et qui aurait pu ne pas être
recevable et là on en a décomté 7 c'est
les les les études sur la souris d'une
équipe italienne une étude sur le rat
américaine où le nombre d'animaux est
largement insuffisant je je vous l'ai
montrer c'est ces trois animaux à quatre
points d'observation euh sur le procédé
on on ne sait pas si la la variété non
transgénique hein de référence est
vraiment la plus proche de la variété
transgénique et comme nous l'avons dit
dans la précédente étude euh les les
l'impact de l'environnement des des
pratiques agricoles sur l'expression des
gênnes euh le nombre de protéines et et
des petits petites molécules chimiques a
une influence donc si c'est le les deux
les deux plantes ne sont transgéniques
versus non transgéniques sont pas
cultivées au même endroit ça peut quand
même impacter cependant sur les 24
études il y en a 17 qui qui sont de de
bonne qualité hein qui ont une puissance
statistique bonne qui ont précisé que la
lignée était était isogénique enfin la
plus proche du moins de la de de de de
la plante transgénique qui est qui est
donc évaluée et qui montre qu'il n'y a
pas de différence donc la la conclusion
de de de de ces études c'est que pardon
excusez-moi c'est que aucun auteur ne
conclut à des problèmes de dangérosité
s'il y a des différences mineures qui
sont observées
elles sont réputées par les auteurs
comme aléatoires elles ne sont pas
biologiquement
significatives alors alors à ce jour
donc vous voyez il y a plus de 1500
animaux qui ont été nourris aux EGM
testés sur des
différentes durées supérieure à 90 jours
sur un total de de plus de de
3000 alors en
conclusion
euh je voulais vous dire qu'entre 2010
et 2012 des nouvelles études sont
apparues on est en train de euh de faire
une nouvelle revue bibliographique qui
va qui va bientôt paraître alors juste
pour 2012 hein euh il y a quatre
nouvelles études qui sont intéressantes
euh il y en a certaines qui portent sur
sur les truies avec euh sur une une
génération là aussi euh à long terme 16
semaines euh sur deux générations avec
17 semaines de nourrissage et euh et de
générations également mais sur un temps
un plus long de de 20 semaines il y a
une étude qui vient de de sortir
récemment sur le rat avec un nourri avec
un un riz qui enrichi euh en lisine sur
le sur les truis et avec un maïs qui
résiste à certains insectes donc voilà
euh les études sur sur les les les truis
en fait proviennent euh donc des
publications du projet européen GMC food
qui a été financé à hauteur de
3,420000 lion donc d'euros entre 2010 et
2012 il y a beaucoup de pays qui étaient
engagés dans cette étude et puis grâce
qui va qui qui a démarré en 2012 euh don
l'Europe avec
l'INRA les États-Unis et l'Afrique du
Sud vont réaliser des des études de de
santé sur sur les animaux et je parle
pas du du projet Marl qu'on a qu'on a
largement discuté aujourd'hui je vous
remercie de votre attention monsieur le
Do et le
public merci beaucoup donc on est arrivé
alors je vais vous dire comment ça va
s'organiser oui je je vous donne la
parole je vais juste poser deux ou trois
questions je vous donne la parole on
fera tout de suite sans pause la table
ronde qui qui la partie qui suit car à
la fois
euh Monsieur Albert gany qui va l'animer
qui est chroniqueur à France Culture et
Monsieur vilani doivent doivent doivent
nous quitter on va quand même se donner
20 minutes pour un peu échanger sur ce
sujet et on et on démarre tout de suite
avec la partie rôle rôle des médias euh
vous voyez que ce débat se cristallise
autour de deux grands thèmes le le le
premier thème c'est les c'est les
l'interprétation statistique sur lequel
il y a pour le moins des divergences
avec une demande qui est forte qui la
demande de données brutes et une demande
de de Monsieur Seralini qui dit les
données brut je les donnerai si jamais
monsantau les donne certains dis c'est
déjà donné mais c'est pas sur un site et
je crois que il est évident que autant
pour les autorisations
que pour les expérimentations il faut
aller vers des données brutes c'est la
base du du contrôle par les Pères de
l'expérimentation scientifique et je
crois que ça c'est un sujet qui est
important sur lequel vous vous êtes
exprimé est-ce que l'an c'est une
question peêre monsieur morture est-ce
que vous avez la totalité des données
brutes et notamment sur la nature des
tumeurs par Monsieur Seralini c'est une
question que je vous pose car je le lis
mal dans votre rapport le la deuxième
question c'est les tests à 28 jours à 90
jours ou des tests tout au long de la
vie vous avez indiqué le nombre de tests
qu'il y a eu mais c'est pas sur le même
OGM d'où d'où d'où le ce que je disais
en introduction parler d'OGM ça ça ne
signifie rien on parle de l'OGM NK 603
en association éventuelle avec le
Roundup ou le Roundup seul ce que
Monsieur bet nous a dit tout à l'heure
donc sur ces points il est évident qu'il
y a beaucoup de paramètres et je viens
de recevoir une analyse qui est qui est
parue dans dans le journal Alan food
toxicology de de de flamand qui disent
que pour eux l'apparition des tumeurs
elle est pas du tout liée à ces
différents éléments mais elle est diée à
la quantité de nourriture qu'ingère les
rats je sais pas si c'est vrai ou pas
vrai et qu' y a une publication qui date
de 60 ans c'est-à-dire est-ce que vous
avez limité la quantité de nourriture
c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'il y avait une
quantité par jour donc ce qui dit
certains c'est que finalement c'est
peut-être une grande tempête en disant
que leura qui mange plus et et qui n'est
pas au régime et bien il il a plus de
démar de tumeur que d'autres est-ce que
vous pouvez nous éclairer à ce sujet là
et enfin une question pour l'anè est-ce
que est-ce que mais elle est très
importante si le NK 603 est dangereux
est-ce qu'on en a chez nous puisque le
ministre a dit tout à l'heure qu'on
avait des autorisations d'importation de
NK 603 est-ce qu'il y en a dans les
aliments est-ce que vous avez fait des
études à ce sujet voilà quelques
quelques remarques et puis vous pouvez
vous poser des questions et vous
interpeller sachant qu'à 45 très précise
parce que Monsieur Albert ganti doit
partir à 45 très précis on commence et
on donne la parole à Monsieur Albert
ganti et à Monsieur Villani
voilà voilà bah allez-y monsieur
seréralini a demandé d'abord la parole
puis alors vous essayez d'être court
hein si si vous êtes pas court on
arrivera ce que j'avais malheureusement
prévu c'est-à-dire que avec des
interventions de 12 minutes ou 13
minutes de moyenne au lieu des 7 minutes
en moyenne si si ça a été ça et moi je
fais des moyennes et bien on arrive à
des débats qui sont des débats euh un
tout peu
biaiser nous avons fait une une
métaanalyse en 2011 sur la quarantaine
d'OGM tolérant au RUP et ou contenant
des pesticides puisque euh je ne
voudrais pas escamoter le débat du fait
que les OGM puissent être toxiques à
cause des pesticides qu'ils contiennent
euh et qu'ils sont faits pour contenir
puisquils ont été modifi je me concentre
moi aussi je favorise les OGM au niveau
du laboratoire pour étudier le rôle des
gènes pour les médicaments pour faire
autre chose tant qu'on est en milieu
confiné il ne s'agit pas de prendre
l'assiette du consommateur pour la
paillasse du scientifique sans avoir
testé les EGM voilà ce que nous avons
réalisé donc je voudrais revenir sur le
fait que je ne suis pas d'accord avec
les interprétations de Madame RIC parce
queon ne peut pas mélanger la carpe le
lapin et la vache c'est des expériences
vie entières qui peuvent être
comparables et sur un même OGM et donc
je tiens à souligner ce que vous venez
de dire monsieur leodo que aucune de ces
expériences ne portait sur le maïs OGM
NK 603 et aucune sur le Roundup à ma
connaissance n'a été faite avec la vie
entière mais si les plus longues
expériences qui est porté sur le Randa
puisqu'il y a là la société Monsanto et
un certain nombre de représentants de
l'îs c'est-à-dire du cabinet de lobby
européen qui défend les industriels et
siège montsantau si ces sociétés sont
prêtes à mettre chez
l'huissier oui mais si les sociétés sont
prêtes à mettre chez l'huissier ou les
agences qui ont évalué ces tests les
plus longs tests fait sur mammifère qui
soient donc comparable avec ces produits
et notamment les l'ensemble des analyses
de sang et des données toxicologiques
alors on verra s'il y a des effets
significatif ou non et comment ils ont
été interprétés ou sous-interprétés par
les personnes qui sont dans la salle
donc ce que nous demandons c'est
effectivement cela et nous l'avons dit
aux agences quand nous nous les avons
consulté nous nous sommes prêts à mettre
toutes nos données sur le tapis à
condition que les autres aussi parce que
il n'est pas question de faire un procès
d'inttention et de brûler en place
publique quelqu'un sans qu'on voit ce
qui est beaucoup plus grave ce qui a
permis les autorisations de mise sur le
marché ensuite il il est clair
aujourd'hui que et bien nous avons des
données qui sont largement insuffisantes
et largement sous-exploité au niveau
statistique et que nous sommes pour la
plus grande des transparences la plus
grande des transparences transparence
bien sûr mais monsieur pages oui donc
moi je voulais revenir en fait sur sur
les projections hein ce qui ce qui nous
attend et effectivement comme je l'ai
indiqué un peu brièvement à la fin de de
mon intervention donc le ha Conseil des
biotechnologies en collaboration avec
l'an et d'ailleurs nous avons une
première réunion demain pour essayer de
de de voir va se pencher sur ces
question des des études qui resteraient
à faire et comme la la indqu madame
parant Massin il y a un assez grand
nombre de de possibilités
vraisemblablement nous interviewerons
Monsieur
B ce type d'approche est relativement
intéressante je voulais juste malgré
tout dire une chose c'est que vous avez
eu les données complètes les données
brutes les deux agences alors le le le
HCB est une instance qui est
relativement jeune nous n'avons pas
évalué le NK 603 en tant que tel on l'a
évalué dans dans dans des associations
et on avait noté que on s'était référé
au aux données de l'AFSA à l'époque
Monsieur je crois que l'ancest n'a pas
pu non plus donner les données brutes de
Roundup parce qu'il ne les avait pas et
et est-ce que vous trouvez alors là là
là autant vous avez raison et je vous
soutiendrai je dirai que dans les
conclusions il m'a paraît évident que
les données brutes doivent être données
pour des processus d'autorisation mais
est-ce que vous avez raison à un moment
donné quand le ministre demande une
analyse à un organisme public français
de pas donner ses données brutes les
scientifiques de comparer les
scientifiques
est scientifique de comparer les
comparables et si on veut puisque c'est
le rôle des agences moi je considère que
l'évaluation par les paires au niveau
des revues internationales elle a été
faite et je n'attends pas des agences
une évaluation de des articles
scientifiques mais une évaluation des
produits au regard des données
scientifiques alors après elle prend sa
responsabilité j'aimerais d'ailleurs que
ce soit une responsabilité pleine et
entière au regard de la loi mais
d'accord mais il faut que il faut que
les données brutes du runup et du nk603
du runup et du NK 603 soit sur le tapis
pas du glyphosate seul ou pas uniquement
mais du RUP tel qu'il a été évalué sur
les mammifères oui monsieur Mortureux
d'abord madame et puis vous terminez
oui tout à fait pour pour bien clarifier
les choses d'abord encore une fois on
vous l'avait dit en tant qu'agence nous
on est extrêmement euh favorable hein à
ce que les données soient
fournies de façon la plus transparente
possible encore une fois dans le cadre
règlement tel qu'il existe alors mettons
tout chez un ISS ensemble pour être bien
clair au niveaués Paraire au niveau des
phytosanitaire pour que les choses
soient bien claires au niveau de la
réglementation il y a deux niveaux hein
il y a le niveau de la substance active
en l'occurrence le glyphosate qui fait
l'objet d'une évaluation au niveau
européen ce niveau européen en fait est
confié à une agence en l'occurrence pour
le glyphosate il y a une réévaluation en
cours et c'est le BFR effectivement
notre homologue allemand he qui est en
train de le réaliser et dans le cadre
d'une d'un dossier substance active il y
a des études long terme sur la substance
active plus un certain nombre d'études
substance active
etcormulant hein et ça ça constitue un
ensemble qui aujourd'hui est au niveau
du BFR et nous avions d'ailleurs
expliqué au professeur gilerriic
Seralini que combien de temps
durent-elle ces études sur l'ensemble
c'est-à-dire sur la formulation
d'herbicide à base de glyphosate alors
ça je pourrais pas parce que
Robin techniquement c'est pas
techniquement vous allez continuer à
discuter je pense entre vous voilà très
important c'est très important parce que
sinon on pourrait pas comparer les
effets à long terme donc il y a un cadre
réglementaire he qui existe par rapport
à ça donc il y a le côté européen et
puis après il y a au niveau national
l'évaluation du produit en l'occurence
donc le glyphosate et un cormulant pour
les pour lequel il existe règlement
enirement bah un certain nombre
d'analyses qui est lié aux données
toxicologiques d'une part de la
substance active d'autre part du
cormulant et ensuite la logique telle
qu'elle existe en langage simple c'est
de tester à court terme donc en risque
aigu effectivement l'appropriété du
mélange et s'il y a peu d'écart par
rapport aux propriétés de l'un ou de
l'autre on considère qu'il n'y a pas
lieu de faire des études complémentaires
de long terme sur l'ensemble des
combinaisons sachant que nous avons
réglementairement la possibilité de
demander des études complémentaires si
effectivement on constate que sur les
études court terme un risque aigu il y a
des éléments qui interrogent un cas
quant à des propriétés qui ne seraient
pas correctement couvertes par ce que
l'on connaît sur l'une et sur l'autre
des deux substances je finis juste par
le fait que par ailleurs il y a des
méthodologies qui ont été développées
pour travailler effectivement sur les
effets combinés en particulier de
plusieurs substances actives puisquon
peut avoir des des produits qui ont
plusieurs substances actives et ce que
nous avons dit clairement c'est que nous
souhaiterions que ce type de
méthodologie soit également disons
étendu à des couples substan active et
cormulant Madame puis monsieur peut-être
me permettrez-vous de préciser que sont
les données brutes les données brutes ce
sont les résultats animaux par animaux
pour tous les examens qui sont réalisés
le poids la consommation alimentaire le
taux de cholestérol les enzymes et
cetera et cetera les analyses urinaires
et Monsieur le Président je tiens à vous
préciser que j'ai été
expert pesticide à l'in de 2006 à 2009
et avant dans la comtox et dans les
dossiers d'évaluation nous avons tous
ces détails la l'agence nous les fournit
en tant qu'expert et c'est la même chose
pour un nouvel additif ou tout nous
avons tous les détails nous allons
regarder le taux du cholestérol de
l'animal 424 et c'est très malheureux
que là nous ne les ayons pas Parin les
avez-vous pour le r up donc
monsieur je ne parlerai pas de cas
précis je parle de la réglementation je
n'ai pas du tout participé à
l'évaluation du Run et de toute façon je
suis tenu par un ou d'un pesticide
quelconque alors prenons un pesticide
quelconque bien sû je parle d'un
pesticide
enexpert qui va faire les experts qui
vont faire les rapports ont les dossiers
je sais bien monsieur monsieur juste sur
ça puisque vous êtes en désaccord nous
l'Office Parlementaire on va fouiller
cette question et dans le rapport qu'on
rendra sur cette réunion de
d'aujourd'hui on aura la réponse à cela
alors justement madame parent Massin je
suis pas du tout d'accord avec ce que
vous avez dit avant mais prenons là une
question
sincère selon vous quel est le test le
plus long quel est le test le plus long
qui a été fait sur un pesticide en
formulation avec tous ces adjuvents sur
mammifère avec les pesticides
actuellement dans la réglementation je
n'ai pas de réponse à vous donner je ne
suis plus expert produit phytosanitaires
mais pourquoi vous ne vous en souvenez
pas si on la réglera dans enfin on la
réglera on en parlera dans dans dans ce
rapport et et le deuxième point c'est
que il est évident qu'il y a à désaccord
entre vous sur la détermination de
toxicité subchronique sur des temps
courts en disant que c'est ce qui doit
être le facteur d'indication d'une d'une
d'une toxicicité je n'ai pas entendu que
ce ce débat soit ouvert il est clair que
à 90 jours il y a suspicion de toxicité
et l'fsa même avec qui je suis souvent
désaccord a dit que on voyait 70 % des
effets nous nous avons vu dans le NK 603
et nous l'avons publié selon les tests
qui ont été faits par la société
pétitionnaire il y a des effets qui sont
hépatoréau que nous avons interprété
comme tel et qui ont été sousinterprétés
par les agences à notre avis ça c'est un
premier point mais on voit 70 % des
effets c'est pas pour autant qu'on sait
qu'il va y avoir des tumeurs puisque
chez nous elles arrivent à partir de 4
mois et bien sûr qu'on peut avoir des
modèles autres pour voir des effets
courts de déclenchement de cancer je
suis d'accord avec ce qu'a dit Monsieur
B
mais reste que il faudra au départ faire
des démonstrations entre les tests
courts cellulaires et les tests sur le
long terme chez les mammifères donc ce
que je dis c'est que nous sommes les
seuls à avoir testé sur le long terme le
runup
même pas dans ce qu'elle publie la
société nonsanto ne l'a fait et donc que
pour les autres pesticides ça semble
être la même chose en
formulation je ne parle pas du principe
actif qui comme l'a dit Monsieur Bellet
a un autre effet tout seul que le le
produit en formulation donc il est clair
qu'il faut commencer par se poser la
question combien de temps sont évalués
les
pesticides en formulation sur mammifère
et là je tiens comme l'a demandé madame
par Massin à m'excuser mais pas pour
tout ce qu'elle a dit parce que la
communauté scientifique ne l'a jamais
exigé que ça pose un vrai risque sur la
santé publique ou al monsieur Paget
juste avant de vous redonner la parole
il est évident que cette question la
question que vous posez est une vraie
question sur lesquelles je crois qu'il
faudra qu'on apporte un certain nombre
de réponses mais pourquoi on mélange
aujourd'hui deux deux sujets qui sont
peut-être liés qui sont les OGM et le
Roundup donc donc oui qui qui pe peuvent
être liés il peuvent être liés c'est ce
que je viens de dire par contre il il
est évident que quand on prend une
souche de rat qui développe
naturellement des tumeurs naturellement
et l'agence flamande je sais pas si elle
a raison qui qui nous envoie une une
lettre indique que le rat ou le qui a
été montré sur toutes les télévisions du
monde était un rat témoin et et que
c'était pas un rat qui qui était un rat
dans les lots al je sais pas si c'est
vrai cétait que c'était un rat témoin
non écoutez monsieur deéo on peut pas
dire ça parce que nous avons pris un rat
représentatif de chaque groupe et
c'était la minorité des rats qui avait
des tumeurs tout au long de l'expérience
dans les
témoins-ce qu'50% de naturellement ce
qui a été dit tout à l'heure qu' faut
qu' cetteur cette question l'ensemble
des données historiques ne peut pas
répondre à cette question puisque la
nourriture n'est pas contrôlée en OGM ni
en pesticides et donc si nous étudions
monsieur leedo vous êtes scientifique à
la
base d'accord alors pour ceux qui le
sont et pour le grand public on peut
comprendre que si on étudie les effets
des m et des pesticides on ne peut pas
prendre comme données historique
contrôle des rats qui n'ont pas été
vérifiés pour leur nourriture en OGM et
en pesticides ça serait complètement
antiscientifique madame paranmassin
n'est pas vrai ils ont été les rats de
l'étude Arlan ont été contrôlés pour la
présence d'OGM les OGM et pas de
pesticides de toute façon et ils ne
donnent pas de certificat comme quoi ils
n'ont pas été nourris avec des comme
quoi ils ont été nourris sans og exist
pas pour les étude historique que l'on a
mais il y avait beaucoup de pesticides
oui mais ce n'était pas le Roundup et je
voulais juste bah il y en avait qui y en
avait bien sûr je voulais juste terminer
en disant que effectivement les les
souches cette souche de rat est connue
la la littérature concernant la
nourriture adlibitum les régimes il y a
au moins 20 publications sur cette
question et ça a été clairement montré
que effectivement
adlibitum provoque ben une fréquence
plus importante de de tumeurs et je
voulais juste terminer sur le point R
ont été nourris de la même manière il
serait anormal sur une étude long terme
de ne pas faire adbitom et aussi ce qui
se trouve c'est que les rats ont
consommé pareil les OGM et pareil les
très faibles doses de Roundup que les
rats témoins il y a pas eu de différence
de toute façon je je compis connaissait
leur consommation journalière mais
évidemment monsieur le Deo évidemment et
je voulais juste terminer pour Monsieur
B il se trouve que je suis biochimiste
et responsable d'une plateforme de
biologie molléculaire des des cancer
donc la génotoxicité n'est pas
nécessairement la transformation donc le
le choc génotoxique principal c'est
l'activité métabolique naturelle de
toutes les cellules donc il peut y avoir
une augmentation et je pense que c'est
effectivement très très intéressant de
de disposer de ce type
d'étude je crois que ça fera partie de
l'arsenal mais faites attention dans
l'emploi du du terme déclenchement de
activation d' checkpoint et Cancer ça
n'est pas il y a pas une relation
nécessaire et obligatoire surtout de de
cause à
effet je suis d'accord qu'il faut être
prudent j'ai quand même pas dit ça à la
légère et je vous passe l'article par
exemple sorti dans Nature de Castan et
bartec qui montre très très clairement
la relation entre checkpoint et cancer
je l'ai pas dit à la légère
évidemment évidemment ce sont des
altérations du checkpoint mais si vous
voulez on on ne va pas dans dans le dans
le détail technique on pourra y revenir
en fin de table ronde parce qu'on a un
peu de temps à la fin monsieur Foures et
Monsieur Pascal et Monsieur B les
derniers et on arrête et on passe à la
partie sur la presse les enjeux de la
communication scientifique merci on voit
que les les débats sont sont passionnés
je je vais être assez court je voulais
juste revenir un tout petit peu sur sur
deux points le premier l'interprétation
statistique puisqu'il en a été beaucoup
questions donc j'entends qu'il y a
différentes méthodes et et différentes
méthodes qui peuvent être appliqué ce
que je voulais simplement dire là-dessus
c'est que les méthodes qu'on a appliqué
on en a appliqué plusieurs et on a
essayé de retenir pour faire apparaître
le maximum d'effets celle qui nous
paraissait la plus favorable pour après
que les toxicologues puissent regarder
les effets en question et juger de leur
plausibilité biologique et puis autre
point l'incess a écrit un rapport sur
l'analyse statistique des études de 90
jours euh et c'est les les mêmes
statisticiens qui se sont penchés donc
sur les données de de l'étude
deini que ceux qui ont écrit ce rapport
et donc ont employé les mêmes les mêmes
méthodologies après elles sont elles
sont toutefois évolutif ça c'est
possible et deuxième point sur lequel je
voulais je
voulais le résultat de ces rapports
c'est qu'il n'était pas content des
études de
t on a toujours dénoncé un manque de
puissance et on a toujours souhaité que
c ces choses évoluent ça a été
longuement écrit et débattu je vouais
juste revenir sur un petit point parce
qu'il juste sur puisque quelque chose on
été dit sur les les experts dire qu'il y
avait des compétences en biotechnologie
à l'étranger je voulais juste profiter
pour saluer le travail des experts qui
très rapidement quand même sur sur ce
cette donnée là se sont mobilisé pour
pouvoir rendre un un un quelque enfin un
avis qui ont beaucoup travaillé donc je
voulais juste en profiter pour les
saluer car ils font un travail qui n'est
pas facile ils sont souvent beaucoup
décriés donc je souhaitais en profiter
et à la fois dire que nos nos procédures
d'appel à candidature sont complètement
ouverts notamment que ça soit pour les
biotechnologies et tous les autres et
qu'on appelle ces experts à à se
présenter et que dès lors que les
conflits d'intérêts ne sont pas ne sont
pas avérés ou des risque de conflit
d'avér conflit d'intérêt ne sont pas
avérés on pourra tout à fait les retenir
mais en tout cas merci à nos à nos
experts 45 secondes monsieur BL pour 45
ça sera pas plus long moi je suis
surpris du du refus de prendre en compte
des témoins historiques et donc je me
demande si le laboratoire dans lequel a
été réalisé l'expérimentation animale
dispose de témoins
vous avez vu qu'il y a je me permets de
répondre rapidement vous avez vu que
Madame ricro votre voisine que vous
connaissez bien puisque vous êtes
co-auteur de l'étude a souligné le petit
nombre d'études à long terme sur le rat
et l'ensemble de ces études aujourd'hui
qui sont sur le rat à 2 ans avec
d'autres produits que lesogm et les
pesticides n'ont pas vérifié s'il y
avait des OGM ou des pesticides dans
l'alimentation donc je réfute
scientifiquement l'idée qu'on puisse
utiliser des données historiques pour
comparer nos contrôles que tout le monde
comprenne c'est des d'autres études où
les rat ont mangé des régimes normaux si
ces régimes n'ont pas été vérifiés en
OGM et en pesticides ce ne sont pas les
bons contrôles par rapport à notre étude
alors Monsieur B pour la conclusion de
cette première partie on enchaîne
immédiatement sur la deuxème bon c'était
pas vraiment une conclusion mais c'est
pour dire quand même que qui qui est OGM
c'est le maïs qui a fait les cancers S
réserve que les statistiques et bon et
aujourd'hui je dois dire que je suis
beaucoup plus troublé que je l'étais en
d'accord non je parle de l'OGM lui-même
hein donc si c'est vrai ça veut dire que
le maïs d'abord ça veut dire que c'est
une très grande découverte scientifique
c'est une très grande découverte parce
que ça veut dire que le maïs OGM parce
qu'il est OGM a réussi à produire
quelque chose peut-être pour s'éliminer
lui-même c'est-à-dire un génotoxique et
donc et le le rat a s'il a attrapé un
cancer à cause de de ça c'est parce
qu'il y a un géotoxique il y a pas
besoin de 10 ans 4 ans 20 ans pour faire
ces études il suffit de regarder d'après
moi dans le maïs OGM s'il produit ou non
un génotoxique c'est relativement facile
à faire sur un système cellulaire il y a
pas besoin des 4 ans je suis désolé et
il y a pas besoin des centaines de monie
monsieur bet merci de cette suggestion
sur les alternatives à l'expérimentation
animale puisqu'il s'agit de cela euh ce
que nous avions mis dans le rapport de
l'office et je passe tout de suite
au deuxè thème on fera une pause après
et on aura un peu plus de temps pour la
fin n'ayez pas peur les ceux qui sont à
la dernière table ronde on
est on est sur le thème de la
communication scientifique et il est
évident que on a des journalistes et des
présidents d'association de journalistes
qui ont accepté de venir sur ce sujet et
on donnera également la parole à
quelqu'un qui n'est pas journaliste qui
est Cédric Villani mdaille fields 2010
un des grands scientifiques français qui
nous donnera lui son avis sur un sujet
complexe comme celui-làtérieur vu de
l'extérieur donc il sera témoin il
parlera pour des raisons de d'emploi du
temps juste juste après vous et et donc
Monsieur Albert gany vous avez une
expérience de ces débats puisque vous
avez lors de l'enregistrement de votre
émission Séan publiqu sur France Culture
vous avez eu plusieurs des invités
d'aujourd'hui vous les avez déjà eu vous
les conna déjà donc je voudrais que on
aborde ce thème là car le lien entre
science avant la science était des temps
longs il nous venait pas à l'idée moi je
parle déjà en ancien de de de de
communiquer immédiatement sur un
résultat scientifique aujourd'hui la
communication et la science sont
intimement mêlé et il y a même une une
imbrication entre les deux est-ce que
est-ce que il y a des règles qu'on doit
mettre dans cette imbrication entre
science et communication sur la science
c'est en tout cas le thème qu'on
souhaite maintenant aborder et je vous
donne tout de suite la parole puis après
à Cédric vilani et puis après au deux
journalistes président deassociation de
journalistes merci beaucoup de me donner
cette parole et en plus de me la donner
plutôt que prévu parce que je dois
malheureusement vous quitter à
17h oui les règles dont vous parlez ce
sont pas des règles qui sont spécifiques
à au traitement de la science par par le
journalisme sont les règles du
journalisme en général qui ve qui
veulent que on vérifie nos sources qu'on
croise l'information qu'on euh euh fasse
appel à différents avis quand il y a
débat or là ce qui s'est passé c'est un
peu pas le contraire mais pratiquement
euh la publication qui est qui a été
faite et comme nous l'a dit le ministre
c'est dans cette revue qui n'est pas une
revue scientifique qu'il en a pris
connaiss connaissance euh cette
publication a été faite fait avant même
qu'il y ait débat avant même que les
scientifiques du secteur a plus en
prendre connaissance et éventuellement
réagir et apporter un autre regard donc
c'est pas du tout comme ça qu'en général
on essaie de fonctionner souvent quand
il y a des embargot ça a été aussi
mentionné ces embargot concerne
l'ensemble des journalistes et les
études sont disponibles pour l'ensemble
des journalistes quelques temps avant
leur publication effective dans une
revue ce qui laisse le temps au
journalistes d'aller voir d'aller
prendre des avis d'aller interroger des
des personnes qui sont compétentes dans
le sujet pour essayer de comparer un
petit peu et d'évaluer par avec nos
pauvres faible moyen d'évaluer une
nouvelle scientifique une expérience ou
un résultat ça arrive très souvent et on
n'est pas toujours d'ailleurs en mesure
de de cette de faire cette évaluation
quand on a annoncé que les neutrinau
allent plus vite que la lumière il était
difficile au journalistes d'aller
vérifier et d'ailleurs quiconque
d'autres dans la science
pouvit le faire puisque c'est une
expérience qui est unique mais dans
souvent quand même il est possible
d'obtenir la vie de certains experts
parfois plusieurs qui sont
contradictoires là ça a été un problème
de timing comme vous l'avez souligné ça
a été beaucoup trop vite pour que l'on
puisse avoir ce recul et moi
personnellement je suis pas du tout
d'accord avec la décision la la
stratégie du Nouvel Observateur pour le
nommer dans cette situation je le dis
publiquement invité on avait
invité bah c'est assez dommage parce que
ça aurait été bien qu'ils expliquent les
raisons pour lesquelles eux ont choisiss
cette publication dans ces
conditions
et le problème aussi et c'est peut-être
une évolution de la science dont il
faudra tenir compte à l'avenir je pense
que giléric Seralini et son équipe du
crène ont à
l'évidence planifier une forme de
d'opération médiatique et et qui s'est
poursuivi au-delà du Nouvel Observateur
par
également un livre puis un documentaire
au cinéma et à la télévision donc on
sembl bien qu'il y a eu une
planification de cette opération et
au-delà on voit assez mal les liens
entre une science telle que on l'imagine
souvent assez sereine assez d'abord qui
a lieu dans un débat entre les pères
c'est-à-dire là c'est le cas parce qu'il
y a eu cette publication scientifique
mais ça n'est pas le cas de la commun
communauté scientifique au sens plus
large avant d'arriver dans les médias
c'est-à-dire que là on voit bien cet
après-midi qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est
une discussion d'experts et nous on a
envie en tant que journaliste de dire
mettez-vous d'accord et ensuite
peut-être on pourra avoir un discours
pour le grand public car là on voit bien
que ce discours n'est pas prêt c'est
comme s'il était encore à l'état de
Total ébauche et que beaucoup de points
manquent beaucoup de de discussions
entre vous ne sont pas réglées alors je
vois pas comment nous on pourrait faire
le tri et on a bien vu parce que là
comme vous le faisiez également vous y
faisiez référence vendredi dernier
encore pendant l'émission sciences
publiqu on avez deux personnes de chaque
camp entre guillemets et on voit bien
que le discours le dialogue dans cette
instance là c'estàd une émission de
radio n'est pas possible et c'est pas là
non plus que le problème sera tranché
donc nous ce cas de figure nous m dans
une situation vraiment difficile euh on
peut soit adhérer à un camp contrôle aut
ce qui est très très malsin à mon avis
pour la presse soit rester en dehors et
de toute façon on a un mal fou à
expliquer au grand public pour le dire
simplement les termes d'un débat qui
n'est pas arrivé à maturité pour être
communiqué à ce grand public donc voilà
ce que moi je voulais dire très
rapidement je pense que il faut que la
communauté scientifique on l'a vu à
travers des instances comme ces six
académies qui se sont associées pour un
commun qui est très inquiétant puisque
il plaide pour une espèce de prise de
contrôle de la de la science par de
l'intérieur des médias par des des
commissaires dont on sait pas exactement
quel serait leur origine et leur
fonction exacte mais c'est son des
propos qui sont très inquiétants on VO
donc qu' y a un malaise et ce genre de
propos arrive souvent quand c'est un
petit peu la la pagaille et qu'on ne
sait plus trop comment retrouver un
certain ordre mais j'espère qu'on va
arriver à d'autres solutions que les
instances scientifiques vont jouer leur
rôle et que les scientifiques eux mêmes
vont éviter dans la mesure du possible
de céder à des tentatives de
médiatisation ultra rapide pour
retrouver un minimum de sérénité et
peut-être donc une matière que nous nous
tenterons de transmettre au grand public
dans les meilleures conditions
voilà voilà pour les travaux de l'OPEX
c'est cette table ronde consacrée à
l'étude très controversée du professeur
calini sur le maïs nique si vous
souhaitez revoir cette table ronde notre
site Internet
publsena.fr à très bientôt sur notre
antenne